Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Chaos Radio 206. Hardwarehacking, die Basics. Für Anfänger durfte ich das nicht nennen. Wir sind heute wieder live aus dem Chaos Computer Club in Berlin. Falls ihr noch vorbeikommen wollt, Marienstraße 11 in Berlin-Mitte. Da kann man einfach zugucken, wie wir Radio machen. Das kann man auch im Internet unter streaming.media.ccc.de. Bevor wir heute mit dem eigentlichen Thema anfangen, habe ich noch sozusagen eine kleine Hausmeisterei für diese Sendung. Möchte an dieser Stelle schon mal Dennis vorstellen, der, glaube ich, das Saalmikrofon hat, das wir auch hier haben. Hallo, guten Tag, Dennis. Und der Peter, der gleich auch was dazu sagen wird. Ihr beide habt gerade unisono gesagt, ich habe mich fast gefühlt wie im Radio. Das ist ja viel zu lang. Dieser Trailer, das geht ja gar nicht. Und tatsächlich ist das auch ab und zu Feedback von Leuten, die da draußen, also ihr Hörer sagt das auch manchmal. Das ist der Trailer, der hat halt gut beim Chaos-Kongress funktioniert, wo er halt auch die Eröffnungsmelodie war. Aber hier sei er irgendwie, das Problem ist, was machen wir stattdessen? Und da das Chaos-Radio von der Idee her so eine Crowdgesourcete Sache ist, falls jemand einen Vorschlag für einen schönen Opener hat oder selber einen komponieren, produzieren oder abgeben möchte, sehr gerne die E-Mail-Adresse ist chaosradioat.ccc.de. Dort kann man einen schönen neuen Opener abgeben. Und falls wir das Triumphirat des guten Geschmacks, das ich dann dafür entscheide, würden wir den auch nehmen. Bis dahin müssen wir diesen hier weiternehmen. So viel dazu. Jetzt aber zum eigentlichen Thema, wo ich wirklich ganz viele Leute begrüße. Wir sind wie gesagt live in der Marienstraße 11 in Berlin. Wenn mal bitte alle anwesenden Menschen Krach machen könnten. Also wenn ihr, also semi-motivierte Nerds üben akademischen Applaus. Das machen wir heute in der Marienstraße 11. Zu Gast auf dem Sofa direkt sind der Herr Starbuck.
Schönen guten Abend.
Der auch bitte direkt ins Mikrofon spricht.
Das liegt am Mikrofon.
Natürlich, Schuld ist immer die Badehose. Peter?
Hallo.
Mirko?
Kamerakind ist Danimo und Wetter an den Reglern. Wir fahren heute mit einem großen Besteck auf. Hardwarehacking, wir hatten ja schon mal eine Sendung vor, ich wollte sagen vor kurzem, aber die ist schon eine ganze Weile her, die fast ein Jahr, glaube ich, da ging es darum, auf Chips von hinten aufzuschleifen. Das ist das große Besteck, da wurde dann wissenschaftlich auch dran gearbeitet. Heute wollen wir mit dem Hardwarehacking quasi an den Ende anfangen. Also so ganz, ganz einfach. Und bevor wir das machen, würde ich ja gerne von euch noch mal wissen, warum fängt man damit überhaupt an? Normalerweise, wenn wir im Chaosradio über Hacks reden, dann meint ihr ja Software. Also da wird irgendwas sozusagen umprogrammiert oder ein Buffer zum Overflown gebracht oder möglicherweise ist die Software auch sozusagen so eng in einem Gerät versteckt, dass man da irgendwie Chips neu bespielt. Aber es ist und bleibt Software. Was ist denn jetzt eigentlich, vielleicht das dann lieber die erste Frage, was ist denn eigentlich Hardwarehacking?
Also da kommt auf jeden Fall auch irgendwann ein Software drin vor später. Also ich meine, also wir reden jetzt hier von einfach zum Beispiel Rautern oder irgendwie Switches oder sowas. Also so Hardwaregeräte, DVD-Player, Spielkonsolen, die man halt irgendwie dann aufmacht, zerlegt und dann irgendwie sich die Innereien anguckt und im Zweifelsfall auch Dinge damit tut.
Also sagen, die Grenze ist fließend?
Definitiv. Also ich glaube heutzutage so richtig doll nur Hardwarehacks gibt es fast gar nicht mehr, weil halt in jedem Hardwaregerät inzwischen irgendwie auch ein Prozessor drin ist und ein Speicher drin ist und da auch Software drauf läuft.
Aber würdest du dann quasi sagen, ein Hardwarehack ist es dann, wenn man anfängt, den Gehäusedeckel abzunehmen?
Das gehört dann auf jeden Fall dazu. Hardware ist irgendwas, wo man nicht in die Tastatur hemmert, um es zu hacken, sondern der Rest.
Ich stelle mir das mit einem Lötkolben vor. Nimm mal einen Lötkolben dazu.
Zum Beispiel. Das ist das Grundlegende, wenn man Hardwarehacken macht.
Ich habe in der Vorbereitungstherzüge den Hammer. War das das Frustinstrument oder braucht man manchmal wirklich einen Hammer?
Also ich habe auf jeden Fall schon eine Schleifmaschine benutzt, um Sachen aufzumachen. Natürlich irgendwie Kneifzangen, Wurzangen, diverse große Zangen. Hammer glaube ich bisher tatsächlich noch nicht. Doch, doch, doch. Ein Eprom aufmachen. Hammer und Schraubenzieher, dann setzt man ein Gehäuse an und haut gegen und dann ist der Deckel ab.
Also Eprom ist sozusagen, wie normale Menschen kennen den Chip ja sozusagen, ist dieses schwarze Kästchen, da kommen so Beinchen raus. Das ist aber eigentlich auch nur ein Gehäuse.
Genau, also ich rede davon, also beim Eprom ist es so, dass du auch dieses gleiche Gehäuse hast und hast oben halt so einen kleinen Deckel drin, weil früher hat man die halt mit UV belichtet, um sie wieder zu löschen. Genau, das Glasfenster. Und um an den Chip ranzukommen, muss man halt irgendwie den Deckel abmachen mit dem Glasfenster und da ist es am einfachsten tatsächlich ein Hammer zu nehmen und ein Schraubenzieher setzt man an der Seite an, haut einmal gegen und dann macht es plopp und der Deckel ist ab.
Hardwarehacking mit dem Hammer, auch das wäre ein schöner Name für die Sendung gewesen. So, Peter, warum eigentlich Hardwarehacking? Also sagen, an welchem Punkt sagst du, ist Hardwarehacking notwendig und was kann man damit erreichen?
Na, also es gibt sicherlich verschiedene Motivationen, das zu tun. Also wir hatten ja zum Beispiel neulich das Chaosradio, wo es um die Anti-Feature geht. Manchmal ist Hardwarehacking nötig, um ein Anti-Feature in einem Gerät zu beseitigen.
Noch mal kurz erklären, was das ist für alle, die die Sendung machen.
Wenn ein Gerät eine Funktion hat, die man gar nicht haben will, aber die der Hersteller einem trotzdem unbedingt aufdrücken möchte. Oder einfach auch vielleicht Erforschungstrang. Man hat um sich herum jede Menge so kleine schwarze blinkende Kisten, aber man weiß gar nicht so genau, was die machen. Mal reingucken, mal schauen, wie die eigentlich funktionieren oder vielleicht Features nachrüsten.
Ich glaube Features nachrüsten ist ein ganz wichtiges Beispiel dabei. Also zum Beispiel ein anderes Betriebssystem drauflaufen zu lassen, mehr Sachen, also dass man nicht nur zocken kann, sondern zum Beispiel auch DVDs gucken oder sowas.
Aber das hört sich für mich tatsächlich so an, dass das Hardwarehacking erst mal tatsächlich nur sozusagen, sich den Zugang zu einem Gerät zu verschaffen, um dann dort neue Software draufzuspielen.
Also wie gesagt, so richtig ganz klar, nur Hardwarehacking-Sachen ist heutzutage schwierig oder irgendwie kaum noch da.
Also in den meisten Geräten ist ja heutzutage auch ein General Purpose Computer drin, wo einfach Software drauf läuft. Und die haben dann noch so definierte Schnittstellen meistens, die einfach immer mit einher kommen. Und an diese kann man dann halt einfach noch Hardware-Mods ranhängen, zum Beispiel irgendwie Hardware-Funktionalität nachrüsten über eine serielle Schnittstelle oder über Bussysteme. Da gibt es SPI und diverse andere.
Ist es schon auch möglich, noch etwas extra dran zu hängen? Eine extra Lampe, ein extra Lautsprecher, ein extra Sensor, ein extra was auch immer.
Ich habe ein Beispiel für Hardwarehacking ohne Software. Hab ich vor ein paar Wochen gemacht, oder besser gesagt ein Freund hier hat das gemacht. Mir war es zu klein zum Gucken. Und zwar hatte ich einen Tom-Tom, der hatte einen USB-Anschluss und Stromanschluss. Und der Stromanschluss, ich glaube, mein Netzteil war aber kaputt. Und dann dachte ich, eigentlich müsste man das Scheißding auch über USB laden können. Also hat er das dann umgelötet von dem USB-Anschluss zu dem Netzstecker. Und schon konnte man das Ding über USB laden, hat nichts mit Software zu tun. Und jetzt funktioniert das Teil wieder.
Also sagen, im Gerät die...
Einfach eine Leitung von dem USB-Strom, der nicht genutzt wurde, zu dem Netzteilstecker rübergelegt, sodass der Strom von einer anderen Quelle kommt. Und jetzt lädt er über USB.
Das hört sich relativ einfach an. Kann man das...
Das war auch ganz easy. So eine Leitung löten, zwei Punkte, fertig.
Muss man nur wissen, wo es ist.
Genau, kann man ja messen. Wo USB sind ja nur vier Leitungen, dann muss man denen raus hin, wo der Strom liegt. Bei dem Netzteil muss man nicht den Ground nehmen, sondern da, wo halt die 5 Volt anliegen und fertig.
Muss man nur messen.
Genau, muss man nur messen.
Nachher noch mal genauer drauf eingehen.
Das ist doch wieder bei den Geräten, die man braucht.
Messen kommt auf jeden Fall noch.
Genau, in dem Fall hier dann halt ein Voltmeter.
Okay, da kommen wir noch dazu auf jeden Fall. Hat das dieses... Also das ist jetzt sagen jetzt praktisch, gibt es auch so, also Hacks ist ja am Volksmund immer dieses Sicherheitslücken. Kann man auch sozusagen seine Geräte sicherer slash unsicherer machen oder zerforschen, wie es so schön heißt?
Du meinst sie kaputt machen dabei?
Naja, oder Dinge rausfinden, wie man da rankommt an Dinge, die man nicht...
Also der Klassiker wahrscheinlich ist oder sagen wir, ein Beispiel wäre zum Beispiel das ein EC-Kartenterminal, wo halt man will halt irgendwie an die Inne reinkommen. Also die sind natürlich gut geschützt, wie zum Beispiel die Keys. Und da hast du halt relativ viele hardwarebasierte Sicherungsmechanismen. Das heißt irgendwie, du musst es tatsächlich aufmachen und kaputt machen und Sachen auseinandernehmen, um rauszufinden, wie es im Endeffekt funktioniert, um dann beim nächsten die Sachen umgehen zu können. Also da sind zum Beispiel Drähte ins Gehäuse eingebaut, die halt abgefragt werden. Und wenn man den Draht halt irgendwie kaputt macht beim Aufmachen, dann werden die Keys gelöscht. Das heißt, man muss halt erst mal ins Aufmachen, sieht halt wo, da gehen die Drähte lang. Das heißt, beim nächsten Mal muss man halt die Drähte vorher überbrücken, bevor man sie kaputt macht.
Und habt ihr auch schon, so zu sagen, Geräte auseinandergebaut, dann entdeckt, oh, entschuldigen Sie, das macht ja noch Dinge, die sollst du eigentlich gar nicht tun. Oder findet man das nicht durch Hardwarehacking raus?
Also zum Beispiel, was man rausfindet, USB-Sticks gab es relativ, also vor einer Weile oder ja, den Fall, dass halt irgendwie kleinere USB-Chips verbaut wurden in den Sticks, die haben halt behauptet, es wären vier Gigabyte. Und wenn man es aufgemacht hat, hat man den Chip angeguckt und hat gesehen irgendwie, oh, das sind ja nur zwei Gigabyte. Oder Kondensatoren ist auch so ein klassisches Beispiel. So riesengroße Kondensatoren, wo drauf steht, für 300 Volt gängig und machen so und so viel Verrat. Wenn man es aufmacht, hängt da so ein ganz kleiner Mikro-Kondensator drinne, der halt natürlich sofort, wenn man Strom anliegt, irgendwie durchbrennt. Aber genau, so was, das ist dann so klassische Hardware-Sachen, die man rausfindet, die man, also es ist gut, dass man sie rausgefunden hat, aber will man natürlich eigentlich nicht.
Also oft ist halt auch ein Hardware-Hack notwendig, um danach weitere klassische Software-Hacks zu machen. Also Geräte, die dir keine Schnittstelle bieten auf den ersten Blick, wo du normalerweise anders drangehen würdest, musst du dir vielleicht diese Schnittstelle erstmal freilegen oder finden und dann kannst du halt Dinge machen, die man sonst auf anderen Wegen tun würde. Also manchmal ist das auch einfach nur Mittel zum Zweck.
Genau, man weiß ja auch erstmal gar nicht, was in dem Gerät drin ist und diese Information was für ein Chip da drin ist, welche Komponenten und so weiter. Die stehen ja nicht auf dem Gehäuse drauf oder in der Bedienungsanleitung. Also da muss man ja erstmal ein bisschen nachforschen und das macht man meistens, indem man das Gerät erstmal aufmacht, sich irgendwie eine Schnittstelle sucht und der vielleicht Informationen ausgegeben werden und diese dann ausliest und auswertet.
Genau, also welche Komponenten, welche Komponenten drinnen sind, wie sie zusammengeschaltet sind, wie sie halt verdrahtet sind und wo da vielleicht Pins nach außen gelegt werden, wo man dann irgendwie mal raufgucken kann.
Ist das, wenn ich so ein Gerät aufmache? Also ich hab jetzt... Okay, Beispiel eines totalen Anfängers. Ich hab neulich mal... ist mein Rechner kaputtgegangen und ich habe dann den Rechner aufgemacht und habe versucht... Ich habe gesucht, welches Motherboard da eigentlich drin ist, das ich vor drei Jahren gekauft habe. Da habe ich keine Beschriftung gefunden. Ist das so, wenn man so ein Gerät aufmacht, dann sieht man schon sozusagen am Chip oder am Aufdruck, was da drin ist? Oder muss man das dann noch irgendwie ausmessen?
Nee, also normalerweise suchst du halt tatsächlich nach Chips oder Bezeichnungen und auf den Chips steht das normalerweise auch drauf. Du hast natürlich auch den Fall, dass der Hersteller zum Beispiel nicht will, dass du rausfindest, was drin ist und dann zum Beispiel einfach die Beschriftung abpolieren oder irgendwie Fett in einen Globbel eingießen, dass man es halt nicht sieht. Und bei der Platine ist es dann wahrscheinlich auf irgendeiner anderen Seite. Also so die normalen Hardwarehersteller, die halt ein Notebooks bauen, haben irgendwie eigentlich kein Interesse, dass Leute nicht wissen, wie die Bezeichnung heißt wohl ist.
Wie häufig kleben da auch einfach so Kühlkörper drauf oder Klebepaste? Und die muss man erstmal wegradieren, wegätzen.
Wo ich gerade bei meinem kaputten Motherboard bin, die...
Das sind hier nicht die Computer-Selbsthilfe-Gruppen.
Nee, aber ich wollte tatsächlich aber sowas tatsächlich fragen, weil die als Normalsterblicher, wenn es heißt, auf diesem jetzt beliebig technisch komplizierten Gerät ist wahrscheinlich Bauteil XY kaputt. Kann man das eigentlich sozusagen Fingerspitzengefühl und Lötzinnen oder was soll man da selber reparieren theoretisch, wenn man es schafft, dieses einzelne Bauteil zu organisieren, dann raus und reinlöten?
Ich hab da ein ziemlich gutes Beispiel und zwar die Airport Express, glaube ich, diese kleinen weißen Access Points von Apple. Die haben irgendwie so einen Standardfehler, die haben so einen Standardfehler, dass der ein Transistor, glaube ich, oder ein Kondensator halt so unterdimensioniert ist und halt immer der gleiche Chip durchbrennt. Und da kannst du halt irgendwie gucken, ah, irgendwie machst du auf, du siehst halt auch, und der ist halt explodiert, also siehst halt so Schmauchspuren dran. Und dann kaufst du dir halt das gleiche Teil, löst es kaputt aus, hüttest es neu ein und in der Regel funktioniert es dann auch wieder. Also so die ganz einfachen Sachen, das geht halt schon. Also gerade so bei Netzteilen ist halt klassischerweise, dass halt eine Diode durchbrennt oder ein Kondensator. Und das sieht man erstens. Und zweitens sind halt irgendwie zwei Lötpunkte, abzulöten, neu anlöten und geht.
Ich will jetzt gleich von den anderen auch noch so sagen, mal ein Beispiel wissen, aber ich möchte an dieser Stelle schon mal nachfragen, dieses Löten. Das ist ja, wenn man so raufguckt auf diesem Platin, sind ja die Abstände zwischen den einzelnen Lötpunkten wie, also unter einem Millimeter manchmal, macht man das von Hand? Oder ist das nicht eigentlich alles Maschinenlötungs von minimalen Nanorobotern, die da über die Platine kriechen?
Also in der Fabrik bauen das für gewöhnlich Maschinen, aber...
Kleine chinesische Kinder.
Ja, aber selber hast du ja für gewöhnlich so einen Roboter nicht da, deswegen musst du da schon selber ran.
Die Frage ist...
Mit der Lupe dann halt.
Die Frage ist, geht das überhaupt?
Ja, mit einer Lupe und sehr guten Augen.
Also den Kram, den du auf der Platine noch ganz gut sehen kannst, den kannst du eigentlich auch, wenn du ein bisschen geübt bist, löten. Das liegt auch daran, dass dieses Lötsinn sich ja so adhesionskräften unterliegt. Das heißt, das läuft schon dahin, wo es hin muss und sammelt sich nicht irgendwo dazwischen. Deswegen kriegt man es meistens ganz gut hin, wenn man eine halbwegs ruhige Hand hat.
Also das Open-WRT-Projekt hat auch mal 800 Router bekommen, wovon irgendwie zwei, drei verlötet waren. Also da waren wirklich Menschenhände am Werk, das waren keine Maschinen. Das hat mich auch ein wenig schockiert, dass so eine große Masse an Routern wirklich noch von Hand belötet wird.
Und die muss ich dann auch erst noch mal so sagen, relöten?
Ja, also die drei haben wir dann einfach aussortiert. Aber schon allein, dass so ein Fehler passiert, der passiert ja nicht durch Maschinenverarbeitung, sondern das war wirklich ein Indiz, dass das noch händisch gemacht wird.
Hast du noch ein schönes Beispiel für Hardwarehacking? Also ein Projekt, das haben wir schon gehört, TomTom Stromzufuhr reparieren, bei einem Router ein bestimmtes Bauteil austauschen, was gibt es noch so für den Hausgebrauch?
Man kann, also ich weiß nicht, Router sind ja jetzt zum Beispiel Geräte, denen man sehr viel Daten anvertraut. Also der gesamte Internetverkehr geht da ja rüber. Vielleicht möchte man da einfach Software drauf haben, die man selbst auditieren kann, also Open Source Software oder sonstige Änderungen vornehmen, die ja proprietäre Software auf diesen Geräten ersetzen.
Aber Software auf Router spielen, das stelle ich mir schon eher vor als ich schließe irgendwann ein Spielsoftware drauf. Muss man da irgendwas, muss man Router dafür aufmachen?
Naja, irgendwie muss ja ein Anfang gemacht werden. Und wenn so ein Router irgendwie auf den Markt kommt, dann weiß ja niemand außer der Hersteller, was da eigentlich verbaut ist. Und entsprechend muss man halt anfangen, das Gerät aufzumachen, Informationen über die verbauten Chips zu sammeln. Vielleicht ist dieses Modell dann ähnlich eines anderen. Es ist sehr einfach zu unterstützen. Gegebenenfalls müssen Treiber geschrieben werden. Aber wenn das am Ende dann alles gemacht ist, dann kann eigentlich jeder dann einfach über das Webinterface ein Firmware-Update einspielen.
Also das, was man zu Hause macht, mit diesem einfach was Neues einspielen, das ist dann, man genießt die Arbeit der früchten Leute, die dieses erste Mal so ein Ding wirklich aufgemacht haben. Peter, hast du auch noch ein schönes Lieblingsbeispiel für Hardwarehacking?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Lieblingsbeispiel ist, aber wenn wir gerade bei dem Thema Router sind, also wir hatten letztes Jahr auch mal so ein ähnliches Gerät, wie von dem, wo Mirko gerade sprach, und da war uns zu wenig Speicher drin. Und in so Routern, der verbaute Flashspeicher, das ist so ein Stein mit acht Beinchen, den kriegt man noch relativ leicht rausgelötet und dann kann man sich einen größeren reinlöten und dann war da auf einmal mehr Platz, um mehr Software unterzubringen, mit der man spielen konnte.
Ich kann mich auch noch an ein Beispiel erinnern. Dieser erste Router, auf dem wirklich ein Linux lief, der irgendwie hackable war, war der linkseste WRTF54G. Der hatte noch so ein paar Pins, das waren so GPIOs, General Purpose Input Output Pins. Da konnte man zum Beispiel so alte Nokia-Handy-Displays ranlöten und dort dann noch Daten anzeigen lassen, wie zum Beispiel der Datendurchsatz gerade ist oder was die Uhrzeit ist. Man konnte das halt arbiträr ansteuern von dem Router. Das war ein schöner Hack.
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel, weil das halt Dinge sind, die in diesem Router drin sind, diese GPIOs, die sind halt aus dem verbauten Chip rausgefallen, die waren für den Router aber gar nicht notwendig, waren aber drin und kann man halt benutzen. Steht aber nicht im Handbuch und sagt der Hersteller auch nicht, klar, löht doch mal ein Display dran, aber kann man halt machen. Also in vielen Geräten ist halt mehr drin, als man so erwarten würde.
Und weißt du halt dann auch erst, wenn du es tatsächlich aufgemacht hast und gesehen hast, dass dann der Chip drin ist und dass dann noch die Leitung vielleicht sogar auf der Platine rausgezogen wird?
Wie lange dauert denn sowas? Also wenn ich jetzt eine Route aufmachen würde, dann würde ich sehen, ha ha, da sind Bauteile drin. Jetzt weiß man vielleicht irgendwie ein bisschen mehr darüber, wie lange dauert das in so einem Gerät, wo es im Prinzip keine Dokumentation gibt, herauszufinden, ok, dieses Beinchen, was da ist, da könnte jetzt möglicherweise könnte man noch ein Display dran nageln.
Na Mirko, willst du vielleicht nicht einfach mal wirklich so einen Arbeitsablauf für so einen Router mal erzählen, das vielleicht am sinnvollsten ist, mal ein Beispiel zu machen, was man so da getan hat?
Also so Router haben im Normalfall serielle Schnittstellen. Das sind so vier Pins oder zweimal vier Pins. Und wenn man sich damit verbindet, dann kann man schon mal in aller Regel irgendwelche Ausgaben mit einsehen.
Ich meinte noch einen Schritt weiter vorne, die mit Router aufmachen und erstmal die serielle Schnittstelle finden und so.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen, wenn du sagst serielle Schnittstelle, dann stell ich mir vor, das ist sozusagen so eine Buchse, wo Pins rausgucken. Aber man macht erstmal, man schraubt erstmal das Gehäuse auf und dann sind da irgendwo auf der Platine Beinchen.
Ja, im besten Fall. Da müssen nicht mal Beinchen sein. Das können auch einfach so vier kleine Löcher sein in einer Reihe. Und dann muss man da erst Beinchen ranlöten.
Man weiß, woher weiß man, dass es eine serielle Schnittstelle ist?
Genau. Also was du halt zuerst, du machst das Gerät auf, dann siehst du, da ist dieser und der Chip drinnen. Dann weißt du, guckst du ins Datenblatt von dem Chip, weil die gibt es halt normalerweise im Netz. Und dann siehst du, ach cool, der hat ja irgendwie ein serielles Interface mit dabei. Dann weißt du, welche Beinchen sind. Dann guckst du halt, wo die Beine vielleicht hingeführt sind auf der Leiterplatte. Und dann lötest du da dein Kabel ran, steckst deinen Computer ran und dann kannst du anfangen mit dem Serien irgendwas zu tun.
Aber erst mal musst du sicherstellen, dass überhaupt die serielle Schnittstelle ist. Diese vier Beinchen. Und die serielle Schnittstelle sind Signale, die zwischen 0 und 3, 3 oder 0 und 5 Volt laufen. Und da guckt man einfach. Also ein Pin ist auf jeden Fall immer Ground, also 0 Volt. Ein Pin ist dann VCC, also die Spannung, so was wie 3, 3 oder 5 Volt. Und die anderen beiden Pins, die pegeln immer dazwischen. Die pendeln. Und das ist dann einmal RX und TX. Das eine ist für ausgehende Signale, das andere ist für eingehende Signale.
Das heißt, man kann das irgendwie messen?
Genau. Man kann da also einen Osteloskop zum Beispiel ranhängen. Aber wenn man sowas nicht hat, sondern nur so einen Voltmeter, dann kann man zum Beispiel sehen, aha, der eine Pin sind 3, 3 Volt, der andere sind nichts. Und die anderen beiden sind irgendwie 1, irgendwas Volt. Das ist dann so der Durchschnitt zwischen diesen Pendelungen. Und damit kann man dann ziemlich sicher sagen, das ist die serielle Schnittstelle.
Kann man damit auch so ein Gerät tricklen, dass das sozusagen dann einmal rauchen, dann war's das, weil irgendein Kurzschluss drin ist?
Wenn du zum Beispiel VCC an einen Pin ranpackst, der nicht VCC erwartet, dann kann das durchaus passieren.
Ist dir schon mal was explodiert?
Verraucht auf jeden Fall, ja.
Also sagen, das ist nicht wirklich gefährlich.
Das würde ich nicht sagen. Also tatsächlich, wenn so Sachen wie verrauchen, das kann auch mal eine kleine Explosion sein, und dann fliegen die auch mal durchaus kleine Splitter um die Ohren. Da muss man schon richtig viel falsch machen, aber das kann durchaus passieren.
Okay, aber wenn man jetzt todesmutig zum ersten Mal so ein Ding, so eine Brille, so eine Schutzbrille, kann ich schaden. Bevor wir zu allem anderen kommen, gibt es generell noch Dinge, die ich anziehen sollte, wenn ich zum ersten Mal mit Hardware grob experimentiere. Also Schutzbrille ist nicht schlecht, noch irgendwie Handschuhe.
So wie du klingst vielleicht ein Kleidchen.
Was soll denn das heißen?
Also ich glaube tatsächlich, also die Basics, ein Lötkolben und ein Oszilloskop und ein Schraubenzieher in der Hand hat, sollte man halt mit den Geräten umgehen können. Aber so richtig Schutzausrüstung gibt es irgendwie nicht.
Keine Wollpollis auf Teppich.
Das ist tatsächlich gut, ein guter Punkt.
Erkläre er sich genauer?
Na, keine sich aufladen Wollpollis, wenn du dann an den Chips rumspielst, die hochempfindlich sind, dass sich dann mal den Pulli da entlädt, weil du vorher über den Teppich geschlürft bist, weil du dann noch irgendwie Plastahauschuhe anhast, dann ist das keine gute Idee.
Also elektrostatische Aufladung, das sind halt Hochspannungen, also tatsächlich so Zehntausende Volt. Und wenn der kleine...
Tatsächlich?
Also kleine Ströme hoher Spannungen.
Man liest ja immer, wenn du die neue Grafikkarte oder die RAM-Riegel in den Rechner steckst, dann bitte hier entlade dich.
Also ist es nicht gefährlich?
So ein Funkenschlag für einen Millimeter braucht halt 1000 Volt, sagt man. Und wenn du schon mal jemand anderen, der sich gerade aufgeladen hat, wenn du den berührst, dann siehst du schon über deinen Finger so ein 2-3 Millimeter Funkenflug.
Du hast halt ganz kleine Ströme und auch nur für einen ganz kurzen Zeitpunkt. Von daher ist es halt... Prinzipiell sind da keine Energien großartig dabei. Aber halt in so einem kurzen Zeitpunkt halt doch. Und das reicht dann im Zweifelsfall schon, um den Chip dann tatsächlich kaputt zu machen. Also so hier im Vorproblematiken, das ist ganz üblich, dass man sich damit wirklich Chips kaputt macht.
Also vor 30, 40 Jahren ging das noch nicht, weil die Bauteile da noch irgendwie sehr grob waren. Aber heutzutage wurde ja alles immer kleiner, läuft immer mit viel weniger Strom. Also eine Grafikkarte heute, die läuft mit irgendwie 1 Volt. So eine Intel-CPU, wo sind die? 0, 8, 0, 3, ich hab keine Ahnung. Aber es wird halt immer weniger und die werden immer empfindlicher. Also musst du immer mehr aufpassen.
Und dieses, ich fass dann mal an die Heizung an, ist das ein probates Mittel, um dich zu entladen?
Das Gehäuse, wenn das Kaltgerätekabel noch drin steckt und noch geerdet ist, also alle drei, dann wenn das Gehäuse anfasst, wenn es aus Metall ist, dann hast du dich eigentlich auch entladen und danach ziehst du den Stecker aus oder lässt ihn sogar drin.
Also ich fass zum Beispiel immer an die Steckdose. Also nicht an die Pole, sondern an den Schutzleiter.
Das ist halt die beste Erde.
Die Glubbel an der Seite.
Okay, liebe Kinder, nicht in die Steckdose fassen, sondern wenn, dann an die Schutzleiter, aber vielleicht noch über ans Computergehäuse.
Und ich möchte auch nochmal davon abraten, den Stecker drin zu lassen in dem Gerät, in dem man gerade arbeitet.
Wie ist das? Nur zum, wie sagt man, zum sich entladen. Das steht über den Anleitungsheften teilweise drin. Das ist ja nur, bevor du da RAM einbaust, dass du vorher noch einmal den Kasten berühren sollst, wenn der Stecker noch drin ist.
Um sich aufs gleiche Potenzial zu...
Das Gerät soll aus sein, das ist schon klar, aber der Stecker soll noch drin sein.
Also ich dachte, als wir heute, als wir angefangen haben, über das Chaosradio zu reden, dass es heute eine sehr filigrane Arbeit wird, wo wir über millimeterdünne Beinchen reden. Jetzt sind wir nach der ersten halben Stunde angekommen, bei 10.000 Volt und in die Steckdose fassen. Ich denke, das wird noch spannend. Wir werden jetzt eine kleine Musik spielen, die heute von Chip Music Org kommt. Der erste Track ist Clam Dragonfire. So, Chaos Radio 206, Clam Dragonfire war das gerade. Könnt ihr euch runterladen unter chipmusic.org. Und wir reden heute über Hardwarehacking und haben natürlich die erste halbe Stunde damit versucht, ein bisschen Motivation in das Ganze reinzubringen. Was kann man denn damit machen? Was sollte man beachten, wenn man damit anfängt? Und wir haben schon gelernt, man kann damit Geräte besser machen oder vielleicht noch reparieren oder zusätzliche Dinge noch einbauen oder verhindern, dass sie bestimmte Dinge machen. Und wenn man über den Teppich läuft, in der Wollpulloveranhand, kann man möglicherweise 10.000 Volt in sich tragen und kann deswegen in eine Steckdose fassen. Nein, das stimmt so nicht ganz. Hör dich die erste halbe Stunde nochmal an, das war ein bisschen anders. So, bevor wir jetzt ganz konkret drüber reden, wie man Hardwarehacking macht, ist hier gerade während die Musik gespielt wird noch ein schönes Beispiel gefallen, wo mir aber auch keiner so richtig sagen wollte, worum es eigentlich geht, sondern meinte, frag doch auch näher einfach mal nach dem Hacker Bike.
Es gab ja diese Call-a-Bike-Räder, die gibt es auch immer noch, von der Deutschen Bahn, die man sich ausleihen konnte, wo behauptet wurde, dass die total sicher wären. Und dann gab es da Leute, die da ein bisschen dran rumfuhrwerkten, sich herausgefordert fühlten und daraus Hacker Bikes gemacht haben, man diese Call-a-Bike-Räder einfach verwenden konnte, ohne dafür bezahlen zu müssen.
Und was hat das jetzt mit Hardwarehacking zu tun?
Das System war ja schon etwas abgesichert und entsprechend musste man da...
Also prinzipiell, wie sie funktionieren ist, du hast ein Fahrrad. Früher war das so, dass du halt zu meinem Kleinen anrufen musstest, das heißt, du hast die Nummer angerufen, die da drauf stand. Dann haben sie dir einen Code durchgegeben, den Code musstest du an dem Touch-Display eintippen, dann ist das Fahrrad aufgegangen, du konntest fahren zum Abgeben, andersrum abschließen, ein Code wird dir angezeigt, rufst an, sagst den Abschlusscode, sagst wo du abgestellt hast und dann berechnen sie für die Zeit dazwischen den Preis. Und was damals wohl passiert ist, hört man sagen? Genau, dass dieses Gerät, also das Fahrrad selber oder dieses Touch-Display mit dem Computer drunter oder mit dem Chip drunter aufgeschraubt wurde, sich dann der Chip angeguckt wurde, was da drinnen so läuft, was da für Software läuft.
Warte mal, da ist so ein Fahrrad dann mal weggekommen oder wie?
Kurzzeitig.
Sind da Leute auf der Straße?
Angeguckt, analysiert und dann halt genau die Software so umgeschrieben, dass man tatsächlich, wenn man einen definierten Code eingetippt hat, dann auch praktisch und sonst fahren konnte. Das heißt, du hast das irgendwie halt ausgeliehen, musstest halt nicht anrufen und fragen, wie ist denn der Code? Sondern der Code war halt immer ein gewisser Code. Und beim Abgeben hast du es auch wieder abgegeben und einfach stehen lassen und dann war es halt wieder im Kreislauf drin.
Aber jetzt... Also so gesehen war es eigentlich gar kein Hardwarehacking, weil die Hardware wurde ja gar nicht geändert.
Die Hardware wurde tatsächlich nicht geändert, aber die Hardware wurde halt aufgemacht, um zu gucken, was drin war.
Wie und das hat dann bei diesem einen Fahrrad, wo das verändert wurde, oder wurden dann alle Fahrräder in der Stadt irgendwie...
Einige.
Einige, okay. Dann gab es wie früher bei Mittelalter die Diebe, die so Zinkenzeichen an der Mauer hatten, dann gab es dann irgendwie so ein Grünstrich am Fahrrad oder sowas.
Tatsächlich hat, also es hat halt grün geblinkt, wenn es halt entleiber war und es hat halt einen gewissen, also einen gewissen Code drin gehabt, wie es geblinkt hat, um dass man wusste, dass es frei wird.
Es gibt einen Artikel auch bei MCCC in der Datenschleuder. Genau, ich weiß nicht, was die Adresse ist, aber ich glaube www.ccd-slash-hack-a-bike. Hack-a-bike, genau, ein Wort. Alles klein.
Es gibt immer Menschen, die zur Sendung Show notes schreiben. Ihr könnt da gerne mithelfen, das ist auch so ein Crowdsourcing-Ding. Falls ihr den richtigen Link im Gegensatz zu Dennis wisst, dann könnt ihr ihn gerne dort eintragen. Dass die grüne Lampe dann irgendwie Morsezeichen anzeigt, ist ja auch schon so eine Art Hardware-Hack.
Es war kein Morsezeichen, sondern er hat eigentlich alle die Sekunde einmal geblinkt. Und nachdem es geändert war, glaube ich, hat jedes achte Blinken es ausgefallen. Also man muss da schon sehr genau hingucken.
Ich stelle mir gerade Leute vor, die vom Fahrrad gehen und Leute denken, was machen die da?
Das Schöne war, man konnte von weitem schon sehen, ob es jetzt lohnt, dahin zu latschen oder nicht.
Interessant. Sowas kann man also mit Hardwarehacking auch machen. Na gut, fangen wir jetzt mal ganz von vorn an. Was war denn eigentlich euer erster Hardwarehack? Oder andersherum gefragt, was ist denn eine gute Idee, womit man da so mal anfangen kann? Also ich stelle dir schon mal eine Vermutung an, ein Gerät, das man am Tag nicht mehr braucht.
Genau. Also wie ich angefangen habe, das war halt so damals im Osten, hat man ja nichts, außer halt Lötkolben und kaputte Hardware. Und also da gab es halt so Schrottplätze und tatsächlich mein Papa ist irgendwie auf die Schrottplätze gegangen, hat irgendwie so alte Platinen aus Radios, aus Fernsehern mitgebracht und ich habe angefangen halt Bauteile auszulöten.
Okay.
Und erstmal mit dem Lötkolben umgehen zu können, dann hat man nachher irgendwie auch Bauteile gehabt, was irgendwie auch ganz praktisch war. Und im Osten war es ja auch immer so, da wurde halt Wert drauf gelegt, dass man irgendwie auch Sachen selber reparieren kann bzw. das war einfach grundlegender, also muss man halt einfach können, um da irgendwie überleben zu können. Handwerksarbeit quasi.
Genau.
Und als irgendwie so einfach wirklich mal ein Lötkolben in der Hand gehabt zu haben, so als, keine Ahnung, wie 5, 6 Jahre oder so was, einfach mal zu wissen, wie das funktioniert, dann im Zweifelsfall auch zu wissen, dass das heiß ist und man nicht vorne anfassen darf. Aber halt so die Basics irgendwie für, man geht mit einem Lötkolben um. Das kann man dann halt beliebig ausweiten auf, man legt ein Strommessgerät an oder baut sich halt so ein ganz einfaches Radio, so ein Transistorradio. Das sind ja halt drei, vier Bauteile, kann man im Zweifelsfall auch zusammenstecken. Da gibt es halt eben so Breadboards mit fertigen Breadboards.
Achso. Die, Volker, also man kann natürlich sagen, als einfach die handwerkliche Routine damit entwickeln, dass man alte Platinen auseinander nimmt. Es gibt ja auch so Bausätze, glaube ich, irgendwie, die man zum selber löten, die man sich irgendwie anschauen kann. Lohnt sich sowas oder sind die dann zu einfach und man lernt daraus eigentlich nichts?
Ich glaube, das ist ein ziemlich guter Einstiegspunkt. Also gerade, die meisten Leute brauchen ja Motivation, um sowas zu lernen. Und wenn du halt irgendwie nach zwei Tagen Lötbastelarbeit dann irgendwie was hast, was irgendwie blinkt oder am besten noch deinen Raum in allen RGB-Farben irgendwie beleuchtet, dann ist es natürlich ein guter Anreiz, das zu machen oder eine TV vegan, dass du dann irgendwie durch Kaufhäuser rennen kannst und Fernseher ausschalten kannst. Und das sind halt wirklich, da gibt es halt fertige Bausätze, die kosten Zehner, da gibt es die Platine, gibt es halt irgendwie die 15 Bauteile und genaue Beschriftungen, wo sie hin müssen. Und dann sitzt du einfach hin, steckst halt die Bauteile auf die Platine, lötest sie an und im Endeffekt hast du ein cooles Device und hast da irgendwie zwei Tage Spaß gehabt.
Ich weiß, was mein erster Hardwarehack war, ganz, ganz, ganz früher, 30 Jahre hier oder so. Und zwar der 64er, den konnte man ja nur an- oder ausschalten, wenn man resetten wollte. Das heißt, man musste immer so krk, krk machen. Das ist natürlich eigentlich nicht so schön für das Gerät und dann gab es dann irgendwelchen, keine Ahnung, C64 Zeitschriften, Anleitungen, wie man sich halt so eine Reset-Taste einbaut, damit man ihn halt soft resetten konnte und den nicht mal so hardcore an- und ausmachen musste, oder aus- und an. Und das war, glaube ich, das erste, was ich so geändert habe.
Hat es gleich geklappt?
Ja, war ja auch die eine Leitung an den Taster, die andere Leitung an den Ground oder wo noch immer und fertig.
Ich glaube, bei mir war es ein Betamax-Videorekorder, den ich auseinandergenommen habe.
Das ist doch schon vor der großen sozialistischen Oktoberrevolution gewesen. Was hast du damit gemacht? Hast du einfach nur auseinandergebaut oder hast du auch was damit angestellt?
Ich glaube, ich habe ihn kaputt gemacht.
Mirko hat das mit dem Hammer da reingeschrieben. Peter, war es was bei dir?
Ich glaube, da gab es noch keine MP3-Player zu kaufen, aber ich wollte irgendwie sowas in meiner Stereoanlage haben und habe dann mit so einem 4-Zeilen-Displayern einen alten Computer dran gemacht und 6 Tasten. Und das konnte man dann damit bedienen und ganz schrecklich schlecht Musik hören.
Habe ich auch noch ein gutes Beispiel. Bei meinem Autoradio gab es irgendwie auch keinen MP3-Player, sondern nur ein CD-Laufwerk. Was du halt tun konntest, ist, du hast da, wo der CD-Laufwerk, wo die Audioquelle, also wo der Audio rauskam, hast du halt eine Klinkgestecke angelötet und dann hast du halt eine Klinkgestecke, wo du deinen MP3-Player anstecken konntest. Das muss allerdings noch eine CD drin haben, weil sich was drehen muss, weil sonst keine Signale abgenommen wurden.
Sehr schön. Jetzt haben wir die verschiedenen Anwendungsfelder diskutiert, die von kleinen Hacks zu großen Fahrratausleihen gehen. Jetzt steht hier bei uns, dass wir entweder über gängige Angriffspunkte reden könnten oder über die einzelnen Tools. Was wäre denn jetzt eher dran?
Also ich würde sagen, wir machen erstmal Tools.
Erstmal die einen Tools. So, wir haben jetzt schon gehört, Hammer braucht man nur sehr selten, Lötkolben könnte schon eher eine Rolle spielen.
Multimeter auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube Multimeter ist genau das richtige Gerät.
Ohne Multimeter geht gar nichts. Gut. Weil man fässt zum Beispiel auch nicht in die Steckdose, bevor man die nicht mal durchgemessen hat. Man fässt überhaupt eigentlich gar nichts an, bevor man nicht irgendwo durchgemessen hat.
Ich hab mal Multimeter in die Steckdose gesteckt, das hat dann richtig übelst gebrutzelt und dann war es kaputt.
Dann hast du das falsche Multimeter.
Das ist richtig.
Und dann hättest du auch nicht mit den Fingern reinfassen sollen.
Über 32 Volt ist halt schon was anderes. Da wär ich auch immer noch vorsichtig.
Man soll ja auch keine 5 Euro Multimeter haben. Nicht, wenn man ernsthaft basteln will.
Liebe Kinder, wenn wir in Amerika wären, müssten wir jetzt schon die ganze Zeit dieses Don't try this at home machen. Ich sag's nur noch mal, also nicht in die Steckdose fassen. Auch nicht mit dem Multimeter. Das ist generell keine gute Idee. Nur falls jetzt einer da war. Aber die Leute im Chaosradio haben doch gesagt, so was macht man jetzt mit so einem Multimeter? Also Multimeter kenn ich sozusagen vom Messen, ob meine Motorradbatterie noch genug Strom hat, damit das Motorrad anspringt. Was mach ich jetzt in Bezug auf Hardware?
Das ist übrigens im Zweifel gefährlicher, als eine Steckdose zu packen. So eine Batterie, da ist keine Sicherung dahinter, die dich beschützt und keine Fi.
Aber zum Strom messen, 12 Volt. Oder hat die wahrscheinlich der Moped?
Du darfst nur nicht kurz schließen. Das ist halt einfach viel Strom.
Ja, die Ampere ist keine gute Idee, glaub ich.
Die Sendung über was bedeutet Volt und Ampere und wann verbrennt man sich daran. Die Hand macht man andermal. Was macht man jetzt mit so einem Multimeter? Wir haben vorhin schon so grob gehört, dass man erkennen kann, welcher Pin welches. Aber wie genau benutzt man das und wofür?
Also ein Multimeter hat auch so ein Durchgangsmesser zum Beispiel. Damit kann man schon mal gucken, welche Leiterbahn wo endet oder wo welcher Pin von dem Chip.
Ach so, wir haben sogar eins hier. Falls ihr also nicht nur den Podcast hört, sondern euch das Video anguckt.
Was sind das?
Streaming.media.ccc.de Da könnt ihr jetzt ein Multimeter in der Kamera sehen. Das ist ein kleiner blauer Kasten mit einer Digitalanzeige und Dingen, die ich einstellen kann. So, was mach ich damit?
Zum Beispiel, das ist die Ohnensignal, ist wie gesagt der Durchgangsmesser, wo man gucken kann, wo welche Leiterbahn ist. Und der Danimo, der winkt. Ich glaube, du sollst da irgendwas in die Kamera...
Umdrehen. Ja, doch, ich muss da erstmal einstellen. Aber was genau heißt denn das? Also woran erkenne ich denn? Also ich mach jetzt irgendwie zwei Punkte, verfasse zwei Punkte mit diesen Dingern an und auf der Leitplatte woran erkenne ich dann, ob die Leiterbahn dahingehört und wann nicht?
Also das Ding piept zum Beispiel, wenn es einen Durchgang hat. Und wie Starbucks schon sagte, kann man sich zum Beispiel den Chip angucken, die Bezeichnung in dem Datenblatt gucken, welcher Pin ist jetzt zum Beispiel eine serielle Schnittstelle. Und dann hat man den einen Prüfer an diesen Pin des Chips und guckt mit dem anderen Prüfer, wo ist zum Beispiel der Pin für die serielle Schnittstelle rausgeführt. Und dann weiß man, dass das zum Beispiel Rx der seriellen Schnittstelle ist.
Aber da geht es nicht so sehr darum, wie viel Strom da ist.
Das ist eine blanke Widerstandsmittel. Du guckst halt nur, sind die direkt miteinander verbunden?
Also es geht eigentlich nur darum, ist da Strom oder nicht.
Der Name Multimeter sagt ja schon Multi, es kann viel. Es kann nämlich das, was du vermutest. Es kann dir sagen, wie viel Strom ist irgendwo. Es kann dir aber auch sagen, sind zwei Punkte auf einer Platine elektrisch miteinander verbunden. Also kann ich Strom von A nach B schicken.
Dazu muss das Gerät auch gar nicht an sein. Das ist nur eine Durchbruchsprüfung. Du kannst unser Metallbalken an einer Stelle ranhalten, die andere Spitze an die andere Stelle und dann piept das Gerät, weil die sind sozusagen elektrisch miteinander verbunden. Also ganz simpel.
Hier ist nichts miteinander verbunden.
Halt mal die Spitzen direkt zusammen, dann piept das Gerät, wenn es an ist und die Batterie. So piept man sich durch seine Pladinen durch und guckt, wo die Signale ankommen. Jetzt auf eine Leiterbahn und testest dann alle anderen und merkst alles klar, hier kommt das Signal an. Dann piept es nämlich.
Und damit kann ich aber auch nichts kaputt machen.
Das muss ja zum Durchmessen da auch wieder Strom durchschicken. Und wenn du ganz, ganz empfindliche Bauteile hast, kann das auch schon ein Problem sein.
Dann messe ich jetzt diese kleine Platine nicht weiter rum.
Das muss aber schon sehr, sehr empfindlich sein.
Aber bei dem kann es nichts.
Was fange ich dann damit an mit dieser Erkenntnis? Okay, ich kann möglicherweise irgendwo ran.
So eine Platine ist ja fast ein bisschen wie so ein Irrgat. Du findest ja diese Bahn nie wieder, ist alles so klein und so unübersichtlich. Und damit kannst du halt ohne den gesamten Fahrt verfolgen zu müssen, kannst du halt deine Prüfspitze an einer Stelle ranhängen und mit der anderen Prüfspitze suchst du, wo das Signal wieder ankommt. Du schummelst sozusagen, bis du verfolgst dich die ganze Leiterbahn. Doch, die ganze Leiterbahn, sondern du piepst sie ab, nennt man das. Und Platinen sind ja heutzutage nicht mehr, dass du die alle schön sehen kannst, die Leiterbahn, sondern die sind ja auch mehrschichtig. Das heißt, du musst die unbedingt gar nicht sehen, weil da andere da drüber sind. Und so kannst du dich halt durchpiepen. Das geht halt ein Stück schneller. Wenn man es richtig einsetzt.
Sehr schön. Das kann man also damit machen, man kann also quasi den Bauplan einer Leiterplatte nachverfolgen. Was macht man noch mit einem Multimeter?
Zum Beispiel ganz klassisch die Spannung messen oder den Strom messen.
Wozu macht man das? Ich dachte, die elektronische Bauteile funktionieren mit wohl definierten Spannungen.
Die du vielleicht nicht weißt. Das heißt, um rauszufinden, welche Spannung da jetzt drauf ist. Also zum Beispiel es gibt Microchips, Microcontroller, die früher mit 5 Volt gelaufen, jetzt mit 3, 3 Volt bzw. mit 1, 8 Volt. Um rauszufinden, mit welcher Spannung sie betrieben werden, kannst du halt irgendwie drauf gucken, was da für Spannung ist. Oder du guckst halt, wie deine Batterie noch voll ist. Das ist der einfachste Fall.
Oder auch wenn deine Sachen repariert sind. Stell dir vor, du hast ein Gerät und da ist eine LED, die bei einer bestimmten Sache irgendwie angehen sollte und die geht nicht mehr an. Du kannst natürlich jetzt gleich die LED tauschen, weil du denkst, die LED ist kaputt. Du könntest aber mit deinem Multimeter auch erst mal testen, ob da überhaupt irgendwie 3 Volt bei der LED ankommt. Ob nicht vielleicht schon vorher was kaputt ist. Oder vielleicht die Software nicht mehr funktioniert, die die LED einschalten sollte. Das kann ja alles mögliche Grund an Ursachen haben.
Ich muss mal doof fragen. Also wenn ich gucken will, ob bei der LED Strom ankommt, dann halte ich also den einen Pin von diesem, also so ein Multi-Gerät. Wenn es Leute gibt, die noch weniger wissen, was das ist als ich, dann gehst du zu zwei Fühler quasi. Und den einen haltest du an die LED und den anderen wohin?
Na die LED hat ja zwei Anschlüsse. Und den anderen hältst du dann an den anderen Pin der LED. Die LED hat zwei Anschlüsse und die beide testest halt.
Achso, dann weiß ich doch nur, ob die LED kaputt ist und nicht ob da Strom ankommt.
Also ich würde auch sagen, du misst gegen Gwound.
Kann man auch machen. Aber am meisten ist die LED an Gwound. Ist doch das gleiche dann.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Das ist eigentlich ein wichtiger Punkt. Du hast halt auch so eine Platine für gewöhnlich eine Gwound-Chain oder Rail, die über das ganze Board geht, wo der Minus-Pol aller Bauteile hängt. Alles an einer gemeinsamen Gwound-Chain. Und der Plus-Pol kann an beliebig vielen verschiedenen positiven Spannungen hängen. Und so kannst du halt auch auf deinem Board verschiedene Baugruppen identifizieren oder noch weiter eingrenzen, was mich gerade interessiert oder was gerade kaputt sein könnte. Weil du kannst immer gegen Gwound messen. Das ist halt für alle gemeinsam. Damit hast du eigentlich schon einen guten Angruspunkt. Du musst also nicht unbedingt das zweite Bein der LED nehmen. Du kannst auch irgendwo zum Beispiel so jeder USB-Anstoß an einem Gehäuse, zum Beispiel das äußere von dem USB-Ding, ist auf Gwound gezogen. Da kannst du einfach dranhängen und dann kannst du im Unteren rummessen und gucken, wo es überall hingeht.
Genau, da muss halt, wenn die LED angehen will, muss da eine gewisse Spannung an dem Beinchen von der LED anliegen. Wenn es da nicht anliegt, und es eigentlich sein sollte, dann ist irgendwo was kaputt. Und zwar nicht die LED, sondern halt vorher.
Ah, okay, verstehe. Sehr interessant. Und das ist das, was man mit einem Multimeter machen kann?
Einen Beispiel habe ich noch, zum Beispiel Bauteile messen. Also wenn du jetzt einen Bauteil hast, wo halt nichts mehr draufsteht, oder ein Widerstand. Du weißt halt nicht, wie groß der Widerstand ist. Du gibst für den Multimeter auch die Möglichkeit, Widerstände zu messen. Das heißt, du hast halt den Widerstand, hältst die eine Spitze an die eine Seite, die andere Spitze an die andere Seite. Und das sagt dir halt genau, wie groß der Widerstand von diesem Widerstand ist.
Und das gleiche auch mit Kondensatoren, solange die nicht allzu groß sind. Weil man ein besseres Multimeter hat. Aber eigentlich können das heute auch alle.
Okay, das ist auch nichts zu sagen, wo man sich da einreden lassen muss. Du musst unbedingt dieses platinenbeschichtete Multimeter mit Diamanten drauf für 198.000 Euro kaufen. Sondern was man im normalen Gasten...
Es gibt auch Multimeter, die zum Beispiel Frequenz messen können. Da gibt es halt wirklich Abstufungen. Da muss man wissen, was du haben willst.
Beziehungsweise was du brauchst. Genau. Wenn dich die Toleranzen nicht stören, wenn du nur durchpiepsten willst, dann reicht wahrscheinlich sogar das 5-Euro-Multimeter. Wenn du aber sehr genau wissen willst, welche Spannungen da gerade sind oder welcher Widerstand der hat, den du gerade durchmessen willst, dann musst du halt ein bisschen mehr Geld ausgeben.
Was ich mich jetzt immer noch frage, jetzt wüsste ich theoretisch, wie ich Dinge auf einer Platine vermesse, aber was mache ich dann damit mit diesen gewonnenen Erkenntnissen?
Zum Beispiel den Fehler finden.
Okay, ja, das stimmt.
Also den, den Fall, den Mirko davon geschildert hat, dass du halt ein Chip hast, wo eine seriöse Schindstelle ist, und du hast halt am Rand eine Steckerleiste. Also da kommen halt irgendwie viele Pins raus. Du weißt aber nicht, welcher Pin jetzt zu welcher Funktionalität gehört. Das heißt, du nimmst das Multimeter im Durchgangsprüfer-Modus, hältst halt genau an den Chip, an den seriellen, an das Pin ran, und dann misst du halt einfach einmal alle von diesen Balken durch. Und an einer Stelle wird es halt piepen und dann weißt du, ah cool, da kann ich mich jetzt raufklemmen, ohne seriell zu benutzen.
Nahezu jedes Gerät hat auch GPIOs. Das sind so Pins, wie schon gesagt, die man einfach ein- und ausschalten kann aus der Software heraus. Wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel softwaremäßig auf das System rauf kann und GPIOs ein- und ausschalten kann, dann kann man mit dem Multimeter messen, welcher Pin jetzt eigentlich der ist, den man ein- und ausschaltet. Und das kann man dann am Multimeter sehen. Dann tippe ich irgendein Kommando in das Terminal auf dem Gerät, zum Beispiel einem Router, und sehe dann, dass dieser GPIO auf Ground oder halt auf eine Spannung gezogen wird. Und dann kann ich da zum Beispiel irgendwas anderes anschließen und damit irgendwas von meinem Router und damit über IP steuern.
Zwischenfrage aus dem Saal. Die GPIOs, das sind die Dinger, die üblicherweise bei Plastoroutern die LEDs ansteuern, oder? Genau.
In den meisten Fällen ist das so. Also es kann auch sein, dass da irgendwie noch so ein LED-Controller zwischenhängt, aber eigentlich sind das GPIOs.
Und die kann man sich dann sozusagen ausmessen. Der andere Name, der schon gefallen ist, ist dein Oszilloskop. So jetzt weiß ich, dass man da irgendwie Wellendingen, Frequenzen oder so messen kann. Ich frage mich aber, was macht man jetzt beim Hardwarehacking damit?
Also man kann damit zum Beispiel viel feiner abtasten. Wie schon bei der seriellen Schnittstelle gesagt. Wenn da halt ganz schnell ein Pin zwischen 5 Volt und 0 Volt schwankt und damit 1 und 0 überträgt, und ich da ein einfaches Multimeter dran hänge, dann ist das viel zu träge. Dann zeigt mir das so eine Durchschnittsspannung an. Zum Beispiel 1, 8 Volt. Mit einem Oszilloskop kann ich zum Beispiel auf bis zu 100 oder 500 Megahertz fein abtasten. Dann sehe ich ganz genau die einzelnen Bits, die einzelnen Spannungsschwankungen, die auf diesem Pin vorherrschen und kann Muster erkennen.
Wofür braucht man das? Das ist doch jetzt schon mehr als das Strom oder nicht.
ZB wenn du wissen willst, was über die serielle Leitung rüber gesendet wird.
Oder ob es eine ist.
Damit siehst du, ob da Daten über die Leitung gehen und ob da nicht nur dauerhaft 5 Volt anliegen. Sondern du siehst halt die Signale an, aus, an, aus. Du siehst es ja optisch, du siehst ja kein Wert, sondern du siehst halt ein Bild des Signals. Damit kannst du erst mal viel besser erkennen, dass da was rüber geht.
Oder ob da wirklich Daten transportiert werden.
Genau, und selbst wenn man weiß, dass es eine serielle Schnittstelle ist, weiß man zum Beispiel noch nicht, mit welcher Baudrate da kommuniziert wird. Die serielle Schnittstelle spricht ein bestimmtes Protokoll. Und dann muss man erst mal noch wissen, wie man auf seinem Computer die serielle Schnittstelle auf dem Computer konfigurieren muss, damit man wirklich über dieses Protokoll mit dem Gerät sprechen kann. Und das kann man zum Beispiel mit dem Oszilloskop sehr gut sehen.
Also man kann aus dieser Kurve sehen, welche Sprache die sprechen quasi. Also da braucht man aber schon eine Routine für, oder? Das muss man schon eine Weile gemacht haben, bevor man daran sieht, okay, der macht das.
Also das kommt zum Wissen drauf an, wie viel Intelligenz in deinem Oszilloskop steckt. Also es gibt durchaus auch moderne Geräte, die dir dann schon dekodieren können, was denn da wohl kommt. Du sagst dann irgendwie, ja, ich glaube, das ist eine serielle. Und dann guckt der mal, ob der daraus irgendwie sinnvolle Bitmuster rekonstruieren kann. Und das ist halt quasi was, wie wir am Anfang sind. Du machst diese Kiste auf. Und du weißt gar nicht, also der Hersteller hat leider nicht dran geschrieben, das ist RX und TX, sondern das sind nur irgendwelche Pins. Und dann kannst du halt einfach mal ein Oszilloskop oder einen Logic Analyzer dranhalten. Und dann siehst du halt, oh ja, das ist eine serielle. Oder ja, das ist ein SPI-Bus oder das ist irgendwas anderes. Und dann hast du halt einen Anhaltspunkt, dass da eventuell Informationen für dich rausfallen könnten.
Also mit so einem Oszilloskop kann man halt ganz genau sehen, was da auf diesem Pin passiert. Und in der Computerwelt sind das ja meistens Einsen und Nullen. Und dafür braucht man eigentlich gar kein Oszilloskop, weil man nur zwischen Eins und Null unterscheiden möchte. Und wie Peter schon sagte, gibt es Logic Analyzer.
Halt, ich möchte schon wieder dazu kommen. Ich habe vorhin zum Oszilloskop noch einige Fragen.
Ich würde vielleicht, wenn du gerade Oszilloskop sagst, noch mal einen Schritt zurückkommen. Was ein Oszilloskop ja eigentlich tut, ist tatsächlich Frequenzen anzeigen. Beispiel ist zum Beispiel Radio. Du hast hier Fritz Aufhunder 2, 6 MHz. Das senden wir heute nicht drauf, aber ja. Das heißt, es gibt halt irgendwo in deinem Radio einen Schwingkreis, der halt so genau für diese Frequenz zuständig ist. Das heißt, wenn du mit deinem Oszilloskop, also Schwingkreis ist vermutlich aus einer Spule und einem Kondensator aufgebaut. Wenn du halt mit dem Oszilloskop genau diese Spule und den Kondensator, die beiden Beinchen von dem Oszilloskop darauf hängst, hast du diese schöne Schwingung. Und wenn du die Schwingung genau ausmisst, wirst du feststellen, diese Schwingung ist 102, 6 MHz. Das ist so das Grundlegende oder das Einfachste, was man mit so einem Oszilloskop machen kann, die Frequenzen tatsächlich aufnehmen.
Was für ein Oszilloskop noch gut ist, ist, dass wir als Hacker viel mit Digitalsignalen zu tun haben. Das heißt 0 und 1 und da werden wir wieder beim Logic Analyzer. Aber das Oszilloskop ist auch gut, um zu sehen, ob dein Signal eine gute Qualität hat. Weil manchmal, wenn die Kondensatoren oder Widerstände nicht stimmen, dann schlägt dein Signal ein Stück übers Ziel hinaus. Du bist bei 0 Volt und dann wechselt das Signal auf 5 Volt. Aber das schlägt dann ein bisschen höher und pendelt sich dann bei 5 Volt ein. Mit dem Oszilloskop kann man genau sehen, wie sich die Signale gut einpendeln. Wie sagt man schön?
Rechteckkurve oder was?
Wenn es so rumeiert, dann siehst du, dein Signal ist scheiße. Wenn es zu lange braucht, um sich aufzubauen, oder es ist zu langsam, um sich abzubauen, dadurch verändern sich dann Timings usw. Mit dem Oszilloskop kannst du noch viel mehr sehen als mit einem Logic-Analyser.
Ich möchte hier noch ein Beispiel nennen. Ich habe mir ein Oszilloskop gekauft für ein ganz bestimmtes Projekt. Da gibt es diese Funk-Steckdosen in Baumärkten für irgendwie wenig Geld, 10 oder 15 Euro. Genau, die Lampensteuer, die man da reinsteckt z.B. Ich wollte wissen, wie dieses Protokoll funktioniert, welche Sprache diese Fernbedienungen, diese Steckdosen sprechen. Ich habe mir das mit dem Logic-Analyser angeguckt. Nein, das Oszilloskop, verdammt. Ich habe auf dem Oszilloskop die Wellenform gesehen. Das endet auf 433 MHz. Das ist die Modulation. Die sogenannte Payload sind die Daten, die übertragen werden. Da sah man genau, wie diese einzelnen Steckdosen angesprochen werden.
Die zeigt mir an, das sind 433 MHz. Wo sind die Daten an versteckt?
Das ist die Trägerfrequenz. Jetzt ist die Frage, wie man das Signal da rein moduliert. Das kann man z.B. über die Amplitudenmodulation machen, indem man von der Trägerfrequenz die Amplitude ein wenig abändert. Das heißt, sie wird größer? Genau, größer oder kleiner. Da drin ist dann der eigentliche Inhalt versteckt.
Das heißt, der Austausch wird lauter und leiser?
Lauter und leiser, ok.
Dann gibt es noch die Frequenzmodulation, wo von 433 MHz von 432, 9 bis 433, 1 MHz moduliert wird. D.h. die Frequenz wird immer ein wenig angepasst in diesen Raum. Da drin sind dann die Daten versteckt.
Du kannst dadurch, dass du die Kurve genau beobachtest, weißt du, was drin passiert, welche Daten übertragen. Du kannst den Befehl aufzeichnen, wie du die Checkdose anmachst. Kannst du das dann auch wiederum nachvollziehen? Also du kannst dir selber ein Gerät bauen, wo du sagst, okay, Gerät, sende mal das Signal.
In der Tat habe ich mir dann so einen Chip gekauft, der auf 433 MHz sendet. Den habe ich an vorhandene GPIO-Pins meines Routers gelötet. Auf dem lief dann OpenWRT Linux. Dann habe ich ein Körnemodul geschrieben, das diese GPIOs so anspricht, dass der Chip genau das sendet, was die Steckdosen erwarten. Und am Ende konnte ich dann mit einer Android-Applikation von meinem Telefon über den Router diese Funksteckdosen ein- und ausschalten.
Du hast ja so ein Smart Home Device gebaut.
Und hast du dich dann selbst ausgeschaltet damit? Na, hat dir den eigenen Ast abgesägt.
Du meinst, der Router steckte in einer Funksteckdose.
Könnte man sich vorstellen. Das ist echt spannend. Nur mal zum Vergleich sagen. Ich weiß gar nicht, was so Smart Home Devices kosten. Und wie viel hast du?
Von bis... 10 bis 500 Euro kannst du da alles auf den Tisch geben.
Was kosten so eine Funksteckdose?
So 10 bis 15 Euro. Und der Chip hat 5 Euro gekostet. Und der Router, auf dem das Ganze lief, 20.
Okay, das ist schon ganz gut. Könntest du mit diesem Chip zu sagen, eine beliebige Anzahl dieser Steckdosen?
Genau, also ich konnte 2 hoch 10 Steckdosen ansteuern.
Das ist möglicherweise genug, selbst für einen Nerdhaushalt. Noch mal zur Frage beim Osteodyskop. Wenn man das hört, denkt man, Physiklabor, riesiges Gerät, Aktenkoffer groß, vielleicht sogar größer darin, ein Röhrenmonitor, wo so ein grüner Strahl die Kurve nachzeichnet. Gibt es mittlerweile auch als App so gefragt?
Gibt es tatsächlich als App. Es gibt dein Mikrofon, das sammelt mehr oder weniger auch Frequenzen. In dem Bereich, was das Mikrofon kann, kannst du auch das Mikrofon als Osteodyskop benutzen. Ansonsten gibt es kleine Kästen, die du an deinen Rechner anstecken kannst, die inzwischen das können, was früher diese großen Kisten konnten.
Das ist ein kleiner Kasten, da habe ich auch Messspitzen. Dann gibt es eine Software dazu, die auf dem Bildschirm darstellt.
Richtig.
Wie teuer ist sowas? Multimeter fängt bei 5 Euro an. Sicherlich gibt es auch Osteodyskope, für die man eine Milliarde ausgeben kann.
Wo fängt das an? Wenige 100 Euro.
Ich habe für meins 400 Euro gezahlt. Und lustigerweise war das noch ein Modell, das man aufhacken konnte. Es gab das nämlich in zwei Versionen.
Du meinst Hardwarehacken von Hardwarehacken.
Genau.
Du meinst, du hast Ramen, Wendors und mir Geld beschissen, weil du ja, oh, oh, oh.
Die haben halt die Software in dem Gerät einfach nur abgeändert. Also es gab da zwei Modelle, eins mit 50 MHz und eins mit 100 MHz. Und das ist schon ein ziemlicher Unterschied, die aber eigentlich von der Hardware identisch waren. Und man konnte die Software in dem Oszilloskop dann so modifizieren, dass man aus der 50 MHz Variante eine 100 MHz Variante machte, die um einige hundert Euro teurer war.
Also wenn du auf einen Display verzichten kannst, so USB-Ozilloskope mit 100 MHz fangen so bei 100 Euro an. Aber oft reicht halt auch schon ein Logic Analyzer und die kriegst du...
Dazu kommen wir gleich. Wir hören wir auch mit dem Logic Analyzer. So, der Chat meinte gerade jemand, man kann auch eine Soundcard als Ozilloskop benutzen.
Das ist das, was ich meinte.
Dass er es mit dem Mikrofon und so sagen braucht. Okay, sehr schön. So, da haben wir es mit dem Ozilloskop jetzt glaube ich geklärt, oder?
Jetzt zum Logic Analyzer?
Nein, jetzt kommt erst Musik. Wir machen auch hier quasi fast Radio, nur im Internet. Es gibt noch eine Musik, die auch wieder von chipmusic.org kommt. Ray heißt der Typ, Pure Imagination. Und dann sprechen wir kurz über die aktuellen Ereignisse der vergangenen Monate, kann man fast schon wieder sagen. Rallye war das mit Pure Imagination hier im Radio, im Chaos Radio Folge 206, wo wir heute über Hardwarehacking sprechen. Aber natürlich nutzen wir das Chaos Radio auch um kurz über die aktuellen Geschehnisse in der Welt zu sprechen. In den Nerd News, die heute sagen wir mal mangels konkret korrekten Zeitplanungsverpeil frei vorgetragen werden, haben wir unsere Themen rausgesucht, über die wir kurz sprechen möchten. Das erste ist, es gibt eine weitere SSL Sicherheitslücke. Also dieses HTTPS, das ihr meistens im Browser habt, das hört auf den schönen Namen Poodle. Wer kann erklären, was das macht? Danimo muss ran, obwohl er sich weigert. Danimo, was verbirgt sich der Poodle?
Also wir haben ein Problem mit SSL. Und zwar gibt es das alte von Netscape erfundene SSL. Und das von der ITF abgesegnete TLS. Eigentlich möchte man nur noch TLS haben, am besten in einer möglichst hohen Version. Es gibt aber aus Kompatibilitätsgründen und anderen unschönen Dingen immer noch sehr viele, die dieses SSLv3 angeknipst haben. Und das Problem ist jetzt, ohne jetzt weiter ins Detail gehen zu wollen, SSLv3 ist kaputt. Und was leider Browser irgendwie machen, ist irgendwie, man kann die Browser dazu zwingen, weil es kein sauberes Downgrade gibt, kann man ihnen sagen, ich kann aber kein TLS, ich downgrade jetzt mal auf SSLv3. Und dann sagen die, ja, ist okay, super. Oder halt auch End-User-Software.
Lass mich versuchen, das zusammenzufassen. Jeder Browser spricht zwei verschiedene Arten von verschlüsselter Webverbindung. Also vielleicht noch mehrere, aber zwei verschiedene. Es gibt eine neue, die ist gut. Es gibt eine schlechte, die ist kaputt. Und es gibt jetzt eine Möglichkeit, dem Browser zu sagen, du, ich kann die neue nicht, nimm mal bitte die alte. Und dann sagt der Browser, okay, mach ich. Und dann kann ich sozusagen rein, weil die alte erstellt ist.
Zumindest gibt es starke Anzeichen, dass es sehr, sehr einfach wird. Und ganz klare Handlungsanweisung ausmachen. SSLv3 ausmachen. Es gibt da Workarounds, die vorgeschlagen sind, die allerdings die Standardisierung bis heute nicht geschafft haben.
Ich glaube, bei Heise gibt es sozusagen so eine Anleitung, zum selber nachklicken, wie man bei dem jeweiligen Browser... Genau. Vielleicht ist das ja auch in Showdots.
Im aktuellen Chrome ist es schon aus. Und Mozilla stellt für Firefox ein Plugin zur Verfügung, was es ausmacht. Einfach runterladen oder Chrome updaten.
Und in Explorer ist, glaube ich, auch heute oder gestern was rausgekommen.
Ja, den einfach nicht benutzen.
Aber interessant ist noch, dass dieses Feature, womit man das umgehen kann, dieser Standard dann noch nicht durch ist, dass der auch von zwei Google-Jungs ist. Und sind auch die gleiche oder zumindest einer davon, der den Puddel-Bug mit entdeckt hat. Also es ist schon alles eine Ecke da.
Ah ja, sehr gut.
Schon verdächtig.
Schauen wir mal, was da noch passiert.
Ja, das Puddel-Skype, genau.
So, dann gibt es eine schöne Sache, eine Geschichte mit einem Handy, einem Sony-Handy. Was ist da los?
Ja, man hat rausgefunden, dass die Sony Xperia-Telefone, die meisten davon, mit einer Backdoor ausgeliefert wurden, ab Werk. Das heißt, ich pack das aus und es ist eine Backdoor da drauf. Und diese funkt nach Beijing und sendet alles, was du auf deinem Telefon machst, dorthin, was umso brisanter ist, weil Sony ein japanisches Unternehmen ist.
Ups, haben die da schon was zu gesagt oder ist es so frisch, dass Sony immer noch überlegt, welchen Pressesprecher es jetzt nach vorne schickt?
Nach letztem Stand hat Sony noch nichts dazu gesagt.
Wir bleiben dran. So, die letzte Meldung, da geht es um FTDI. Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, man lädt sich per Windows ein Update für einen Treiber eines Geräts herunter und dann ist das Gerät kaputt. Was ist da passiert?
FTDI baut unter anderem Chips, die man braucht, um mit seriellen Schnittstellen zu reden. Das hat so Fan Mirko vorhin schon sehr viel erzählt. Da diese Chips von FTDI sehr beliebt sind, haben sich findige Chinesen überlegt, wir bauen diese Chips einfach nach und verkaufen sie ein paar Euro billiger. Das fand FTDI doof und hat deswegen in ihrem neuen Treiberupdate eine Funktion eingebaut, was gefälschte Chips erkennt und diese dann unbrauchbar macht. Also nicht permanent, man kann das meistens reparieren, aber der Laie steht dann da erst mal mit einem kaputten Gerät und weiß im Zweifel ja auch gar nicht, dass er einen gefälschten Chip in seinem Gerät hat, weil er das Gerät irgendwie als schwarze Kiste gekauft hat.
Das konnte man nicht wissen.
Naja, also der Preisunterschied zwischen dem Original und dem gefälschten Chip liegt im Cent-Bereich. Also ich glaube, da kannst du auf den Preis vom Gerät nicht zurückschließen.
Wie laut reden, das ging vorher noch besser. Jetzt weiß ich noch nicht, was ich sagen wollte.
Okay, also wir lassen uns jetzt schon bei der News-Meldung bewenden, dass sozusagen der Driver das kaputt gemacht hat. Ich glaube, dieses Selbstjustiz eines Herstellers ist nochmal ein spannender Zugang.
Also er ist nicht hardwaremäßig kaputt. Er ist nur so umgeflasht, dass man ihn unter Windows nicht mehr benutzen kann.
Also ich glaube, für viele Leute kommt das selber raus. Und vielleicht können wir das bei anderer Gelegenheit nochmal genauer diskutieren.
Also vielleicht noch ganz abschließend. Der Treiber ist jetzt wieder aus dem Windows Update raus. Und man ist jetzt, wenn man den jetzt drunter lädt, wieder sicher.
Also Windows, also Microsoft fand das auch nicht so prall, dass sich der Hersteller irgendwie dazu gerufen gefühlt hat, über das Windows Update diese Backdoor praktisch oder was auch immer einzuführen.
Aber geht der neue Treiber auch, der jetzt rausgekommen ist, geht der auch mit den Clown-After-The-E-Chips oder tut er trotzdem einfach nicht mehr damit?
Ich kenne keinen, der sowas unter Windows benutzt.
So viel zu den Nerd-News hier im Chaosradio 206, wo wir über Hardwarehacking reden, wo wir schon gelernt haben, warum man das macht, was man damit alles anstellen kann. Fahrräder, 10.000 Volt Spitzen, das wird mich nicht los, das finde ich total großartig. Oder blinkende Lichter an Router dran basteln oder sogar Steckdosen damit fernsteuern. All das geht. Wir haben auch schon über die Werkzeuge gesprochen. Also wir haben festgestellt, manchmal braucht man wirklich ein Hammer, das ist der selten. Lötkolben den Umgang zu lernen, ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Idee. Und wir haben gelernt, was ein Multimeter, heißt es so? Multimeter, was ein Multimeter macht und wofür man ein Oszilloskop benutzen kann. Und da fiel schon in der letzten halben Stunde, die Hörer, die schon länger dabei sind, haben es vielleicht gehört, oft der Begriff Logic Analyzer. So, ein Oszilloskop misst also Wellenformen. Was macht ein Logic Analyzer?
Ein Logic Analyzer unterscheidet nur zwischen den Eins und Nullen, die über die Datenleitung gehen. Und da man in der digitalen Welt nicht mehr braucht, also man hat da keine großen Spannungsschwankungen, sondern halt nur die 5 Volt und die 0 Volt zum Beispiel, die Einsen und Nullen repräsentieren, kann man mit einem Logic Analyzer Einsen und Nullen aufnehmen und dann kann findiges Software daraus einen Datenstrom basteln und dir sagen, dass da das serielle Protokoll drüber gesprochen wird, dass zum Beispiel SPI drüber gesprochen wird, in welcher Frequenz der Daten gesendet werden und vieles mehr.
Also ich dachte jetzt erst, okay, das ist halt einfach nur ein billiges Osteoskop, was sozusagen nur die Spitzenmester, aber das ist, da geht es tatsächlich eher schon um die konkrete Analyse des Signals.
Also eigentlich ist es ein, also Hardware-mäßig ist es ein billiges Osteoskop. Und das Rest, der Rest ist dann halt wieder ein Software. Also du guckst dann halt, wie gesagt, du siehst halt die Einsen und Nullen und das Tolle an der Software, also an dieser Logic Analyzer Software, ist dann, dass es zum Beispiel auch sagen kann, das sind jetzt acht Klicks hintereinander, das heißt, diese acht Bits, fassen wir mal zu einem Byte zusammen, zeigen dir den Wert von diesem Byte an und können dir im Zweifelsfall dann auch die ASCII-Repräsentation davon anzeigen, also sagen, was da tatsächlich gerade an Werten über diese Leitung übertragen wurde.
Also ist das so ein Ding, was bekannte Protokolle sozusagen erkennt oder kann man damit auch völlig unbekannte Dinge analysieren?
Also die Grundlegende, was es halt dir anzeigt, sind die Einsen und Nullen. Alles andere ist dann halt Software-Frage, wenn du weißt, wie dieses Protokoll implementiert ist, weißt du halt, eine zwei Millisekunden lange Hochflanke folgt einer vier Millisekunden nicht-Hochflanke und es ist dann eine Eins oder so was. Und dann kannst du halt dann beliebig weiter dich nach oben in der Schicht, im Schichtmodell halt hangeln.
Und wenn du richtig gut bist, dann kannst du ja auch deinen eigenen Protokoll-Analyser schreiben. Wenn du vielleicht ein proprietäres Protokoll hast oder bei irgendeiner Firma arbeitest, dann schreibst du gleich deinen eigenen Analyzer und vielleicht schreibst du dann sogar zuerst den Software, um danach irgendwie dann zu checken, ob die Hardware, die dann produziert wurde, auch so funktioniert, wie du wolltest.
Genau, also wenn du nicht weißt, also wenn das Gerät, die Software es für dich nicht dekodieren kann, kannst du dir quasi aus deinem Logic Analyzer Tool das alles exportieren lassen und dann mit der Programmiersprache deiner Wahl da so lange draufhauen, bis die Daten für dich sind ergeben.
Da war wieder der Hammer. Ganz wichtiges Tool. Ich hab das Gefühl, bis zum Osterdaskob bin ich noch so hinterhergekommen. Was Mirko erzählt hat, ich zeig dann irgendwie so Wellenformen auf und kann da so grobe Fehler erkennen. Das ist doch jetzt mit dem Logic Analyzer schon durchaus der Punkt, wo man richtig programmieren können muss. Also wo man ganz tief, ne, da wird der Kopf geschüttelt.
Du kannst programmieren und den Protokollanalyzer schreiben, aber du musst ja nicht, wenn du Glück hast, dann sind da schon ganz viele dabei. Also zum Beispiel für die Serielle, da ist schon einer dabei. Und der erkennt dann, wenn es gut ist, dann erkennt er für dich, ob es irgendwie 8N1 ist oder 8E2 oder mit Parity oder ohne. Wenn du noch die Serielle von früher kennst, dann war es immer 8N1. Von so Modem, hast du mal Modem benutzt früher?
Es geht unter anderem darum, wie der Anfang und das Ende von diesen Bits dargestellt werden, also Start und Stop Bits. Also das N steht dann für No Parity.
Man kann ja die Signale rauslesen, aber was macht man dann damit?
Die Signale, da stehen ja deine Daten drin. Also wenn du zum Beispiel eine ganz normale Verbindung hast, stell dir vor, du warst früher mit so einem Modem in so einer Mailbox oder so einer, wie das doch, wie das Mailbox.
Lass doch mal lieber Mirko mit der Steckdose. Da kann man wieder als gutes Beispiel zum Beispiel nehmen.
Ich würde erstmal mit einer LED anfangen. Also nehmen wir den GPIO, der irgendwie auf Null gesetzt ist, also keine Spannung. Und jetzt schalte ich den an und er ist auf 5 Volt. Und ich da jetzt einen Logic Analyzer ranhänge, dann hätte ich die ganze Zeit Nullen gesehen und auf einmal sehe ich da eine Eins. Und wenn ich den GPIO jetzt wieder ausschalte und wieder einschalte und wieder einschalte dann sehe ich in dem Logic Analyzer so 0.1.0.1. Und daraus kann ich jetzt irgendwie, genauso wie ich eine LED dann in einem bestimmten Muster blinken lassen würde, kann ich da jetzt mein eigenes Protokoll, meine eigene Sprache drüber fahren und kann damit bestimmte Geräte ansteuern, die auch in dieser Sprache sprechen.
Aber das ist eigentlich, da entwerfe ich selber komplett was.
Ja, oder wenn wir jetzt diesen Funkship, mit dem ich die Funksteckdosen gesteuert habe, zum Beispiel nehmen, der spricht ein ganz bestimmtes Protokoll, also eine ganz bestimmte Sprache, namens SPI. Entsprechend muss ich die GPIOs dann in diesem Protokoll ein- und ausschalten. Und da drin dann meine Daten einbinden.
Ich würde das vielleicht noch ein bisschen versuchen, einfach zu erklären. Also du hast bei den Steckdosen-Leisten, hast du halt, wie Mirko vorhin sagte, du kannst zwei hoch zehn Steckdosen einsprechen. Das heißt, jede Steckdose hat eine eigene Adresse. Diese Adresse wird halt in dem Umschalten von Nullen und Einzen repräsentiert. Das heißt, wenn du dir den Stream anguckst, wie halt Mirko sagt, schalte auch mal diese Steckdose ein, dann siehst du irgendwann 010101, was halt repräsentativ für die 23 steht. Und die 23 sagt halt, 23 Steckdosenleiste ist eingeschaltet. Und genau diese Umwandlung von diesen Nullen und Einzen in halt irgendwas Sinnvolles, wie zum Beispiel die Adresse für die Steckdosenleiste, das macht ja der Logic Analyzer bzw. die Hoffnung davon.
Das sind die einfachen Dinge, kann man so sagen. Wie ist das jetzt eigentlich? Ich stelle mir jetzt vor, auf der anderen Seite braucht man da auch irgendwas. Also wenn jetzt immer sagt, man arbeitet mit diesem Gerät und man findet da irgendwie raus, was die reden und sowas, braucht man da nicht irgendwie so bestimmte Programme auf dem eigenen Rechner, die dann mit diesen anderen Geräten dann wiederum sprechen können? Das verstehe ich ja noch nicht so ganz, dieses Sagen, wie dieses Sprechen mit der Hardware, die ich jetzt, wo ich irgendwas dran geloten habe, funktioniert.
Also wenn du rausgefunden hast, was da mit dir redet, also ob es SPI, I2C, eine Serie L oder was auch immer ist, dann kommt natürlich der nächste Schritt, mit dem Gerät reden. Also bei einer Serie L ist das relativ einfach. Da ist seit am Beginn der Computerzeit das passende Tool auf deinem Rechner drauf, also irgendein Terminal halt. Wenn du zum Beispiel per SPI mit einem Flash reden möchtest, mit einem Speicher, dann gibt es zum Beispiel das schöne Tool Flash ROM, was dann für dich die gesamte Kommunikation per SPI übernimmt, nachdem du ihm halt gesagt hast, hier ist eine SPI Schnittstelle und schick mal da was hin oder hol da mal was ab, zum Beispiel.
Ich glaube, man muss noch unterscheiden, was man da jetzt an diese Pins hängt. Also ich kann zum Beispiel an eine serielle Schnittstelle meines Routers, mein Computer hängen, damit ich sehe, was der Router so über die serielle Schnittstelle schickt und mit dem Router kommunizieren. Anstatt meines Computers kann ich da aber auch, wie gesagt, andere Hardware ranhängen. Und das kann dieser Funkchip sein, das können LEDs sein, das kann alles Mögliche sein. Und dementsprechend muss ich halt wissen, wie diese Hardware angesteuert wird, um dann die Pins entsprechend ein- und ausschalten zu können.
Da muss man sich aber schon nochmal eine Weile einlesen, bevor man das so richtig macht.
Ich glaube, wenn du ein Bild hättest von so einem Logic Analyzer, würdest du es auch schneller verstehen.
Naja, ich kann mir das schon grob vorstellen, aber was ich jetzt mitgenommen habe, man kann durch die Arbeit in einem Logic Analyzer herausfinden, welche Sprache ein bestimmtes Gerät spricht. Und es gibt für viele dieser Sprachen, die gesprochen werden, auch eine Software zum eigenen Rechner, die man anschließend damit beschicken kann. Das muss man dann nicht mehr von Grund auf neu bauen.
Also zum Beispiel Modem. Früher, was Dennis von meinte, du musst ja mit deinem Computer auch irgendwie mit dem Modem reden. Das hast du ganz, ganz früher tatsächlich an die serielle Schnittstelle des Computers angeschlossen. In dem Modem ist ein Stein drin, der halt seriell gesprochen hat. Und dann halt dein Computer, hast du halt gesagt, jetzt fiel doch mal die 030... Und das wurde halt von deinem Computer diese Anweisung auf das Modem Übertrag. Und das Modem hat dann angefangen halt zu wählen und mit der Gegenstelle bei der Telekom zu reden.
Und wenn du da jetzt den Logic Analyzer zwischen hängst, dann würde der erkennen, aha, da wird ein serielles Protokoll rüber gesprochen. In der und der Baudrate, in der und der Konfiguration.
Und die Daten, die übertragen wurden, sind die telefonisch.
Genau, und dann würde er auf der Ebene darüber noch erkennen, welche Daten eigentlich übertragen werden. Und so wird Level für Level, wenn irgendwie diese Ebenen erkannt werden, dann halt das Versuch zu dekodieren und entsprechend erkannt, was darüber geht und dir das dann sehr einfach und convenient angezeigt, bis hin zu den Daten, die du eigentlich an das Modem schickst und bekommst.
Mich würde schon interessieren, wie jemand, der noch die was damit zu tun hatte, aber Bock darauf hat, das zu lernen, wie lange der dafür brauchen würde, um das wirklich sinnvoll einsetzen zu können.
Also es ist gar nicht so schwer. Also wenn du halt einen Logic Analyzer hast und irgendwie so eine Schnittstelle unbekannt und du was ran steckst und dann siehst du halt Flanken, Flanken, Flanken, Flanken, dann kannst du halt im Zweifelsfall im Internet gucken nach Encodierungsverfahren und dann zeigt dir die, also es gibt jetzt zwar ein paar, aber es sind jetzt irgendwie keine hunderte und dann siehst du halt, ah guck mal, das sieht irgendwie auf diesem Logic Analyzer genauso aus, wie dort im Hinterhand. Dann weißt du halt, ah das ist Manchester codiert, also die Codierung. Und dann weißt du halt, in Manchester werden Nullen so und Einsen so codiert und so arbeitest du dann praktisch immer einen Schritt weiter. Das ist tatsächlich nicht so schwierig. Also es macht natürlich Sinn, das mit jemandem zu machen, der das schon mal getan hat, weil der sagt dir irgendwie halt sofort, ah das ist Manchester und du musst halt nicht alle Entcodierungsverfahren dir die Bilder angucken, wie denn so die Requenzen dann aussehen. Aber im Zweifelsfall gibt es da sicherlich auch Bücher, die man lesen kann, die das erklären.
Um nochmal kurz auf das Manchester-Codierungsverfahren zurückzukommen, warum nicht einfach Nullen mit keiner Spannung und Einsen mit irgendeiner Spannung repräsentiert werden, kann sein, dass man zum Beispiel Störungen entgehen möchte und Signale doppelt codiert oder so codiert, dass bestimmte Bitflips, also dass zum Beispiel durch externe Umstände eine 1 zu einer 0 wird und 0 zu einer 1, erkannt werden und entsprechend korrigiert werden können.
Ach so, das heißt, wenn ich einen Logic-Analyzer ansetze oder wenn ich so ein Signal beobachte, dann ist sozusagen 0 ist kein Strom, 1 ist Strom, das ist sozusagen die einfachste Variante. Aber es gibt da noch verschiedene andere und die kann ein Logic-Analyzer sozusagen erkennen.
Wenn wir jetzt wieder zur Serielle kommen, dieses 8N1, was du kennst.
Nee, kenn ich nicht, aber ist ja klar.
Bei 8N1 heißt dieses N, heißt no parity. Man könnte es aber auch mit parity machen. Das heißt, es wird zusätzlich zu den 8 Bits, die in einen Byte übertragen, wird noch ein Parity-Bit gesetzt. Und wenn das nicht stimmt zu den 8 Bits von vorher, dann ist das Byte sozusagen die Informationen falsch angekommen.
Eine Prüf-Summe.
Eine Prüf-Summe, genau. Das ist halt nur ein Bit für 8 Bits, das ist relativ schlecht, aber es ist schon mal besser als nichts.
Ja, das heißt, wenn ich den Signalstrom nicht mehr angucke, da werden 9 Bits übertragen, aber die sind für mich eigentlich gar nicht von Relevanz, sondern für mich sind nur die ersten 8 relevant, weil das neunte ist sozusagen nur ein Check, sind diese 8 Bits.
Und jetzt für die Profis da draußen sind nicht 9 Bits, sondern sind 10, weil ist immer noch ein Stop-Bit dabei. Das heißt, es kommt grundsätzlich immer noch eine 1 hinten dran. Vielleicht auch eine 0. In dem Fall ist es mehr.
Die Hörer werden uns in den Kommentaren zu dieser Sendung sicherlich darauf hinweisen, wenn das falsch war. So, jetzt habt ihr ganz oft SPI gesagt, dass das irgendwie eine Programmiersprache ist. Ist das alles, was man dazu sagen muss? Gut.
Nein, das ist keine Programmiersprache.
Ach so. Sondern?
Es ist ein Protokoll, was über...
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen einer Programmiersprache und einem Protokoll?
Beide sind Grammatiken.
Dann sag doch mal, was das heißt.
Okay, aber was ist es denn jetzt? Warum taucht das hier im Hardwarehacking auf?
Also SPI ist ein sehr einfaches Protokoll, was man über drei Pins steuern kann, über drei GPIOs zum Beispiel. Und das Tolle daran ist, dass ein Pin eine Clock ist und man kann selbst bestimmen, wie schnell die Daten übertragen werden. Das heißt, ich kann ganz langsam Daten übertragen oder ganz schnell. Das heißt, ich kann das mit sehr einfacher Hardware oder so, sehr performanter Hardware tun. Und letztendlich ist es der Gegenseite, die auch dieser Geschwindigkeit mitsprechen kann, dann egal.
Und das ist etwas, das wird halt oft verwendet. Und deswegen fällt das hier so oft oder ist das gerade Standard?
Genau. Also du hast eigentlich in fast allen Embedded-Devices oder selbst auch in kompletten Computern und so hast du halt auf dem Board gewisse Busse, die da eigentlich immer sind. Das sind halt irgendwelche seriellen Schnittstellen, weil die sind einfach fürs Debuggen toll und die sind sowieso in jedem Stein drin. Dann hast du meistens irgendwie I2C. Das ist ein noch einfacherer Bus als SPI. Darüber störst du halt ganz einfache Sachen an. Die Endpunkte dafür, die Steine dafür, kosten auch nahezu nichts. Das kannst du halt einfach im Sendbereich aus Board streuseln.
Sendsohren zum Beispiel.
Genau, Sendsohren zum Beispiel. Und SPI nimmst du zum Beispiel in so WLAN-Routern. Die Firmware davon steckt dir in einem Stückchen Speicher und das ist meistens über SPI angebunden, weil das halt, wie Mirko schon sagt, mit drei Lanes ziemlich einfach zu verlegen auf dem Board ist. Wenn du dir jetzt was moderneres anguckst, so PCI Express, was man von seiner Grafikkarte vielleicht kennt, das sind ja immer unendlich viele Pins da unten. Das ist dementsprechend auch sehr aufwendig zu verlegen. Machst du jetzt vielleicht nicht in einem WLAN-Router, um 4 MB Speicher anzubinden, könnte man, aber macht halt keiner.
Oder für einen Temperatursensor oder so. Da braucht man keinen PCI Express.
Aber das ist sozusagen eine von den Sachen, mit denen man sich wahrscheinlich früher oder später beschäftigen wird, wenn man mit Hardwarehacking anfängt. Also für mich fühlt sich das gerade an, als ob die Route ist, du schraubst das Gerät auf, dann guckst du mit dem Multimeter, Oszilloskop und Logic Analyzer nach, was da gesprochen wird. Du findest dann die Stelle, wo Daten rauskommen. Und da liegt dann relativ wahrscheinlich ein SPI an. Das heißt, wenn man sich dann mit diesem Protokoll beschäftigt hat, dann ist man schon sehr weit vorne bei vielen Geräten. Das ist quasi einer dieser Standards. Jetzt steht hier was von einem Buspiraten bei SPI. Was ist dein Buspirat? Ich möchte auch ein Buspirat haben. Was ist der Buspirat?
Wenn die S-Bahn mal auf elektronische Tickets umsteigt, ist das wahrscheinlich möglich, dass du das damit tun kannst. Der Buspirat ist einfach einer von sehr vielen kleinen Platinchen, die du im Internet findest. Das Problem ist halt, das ist ein Stückchen Kabel.
Ich weiß aber, gehört das zum Buspiraten?
Ja, das gehört auch zum Buspiraten.
Wir sehen hier sozusagen ein vielfarbiges Regenbogen-farbiges Kabel. Da ist an der einen Seite ein Stecker, an der anderen Seite ganz viele Pins.
Ja, also der Bus-Pirate ist einfach ein kleines Device, mit dem man mit sehr vielen 1, 2 und 4 Wire-Bussen reden kann. Also I2C, SPI und so weiter, weil dein Computer hat halt so einen Anschluss zumindest nicht rausgeführt. Und wenn du das dann anschließen möchtest, also du möchtest mit deinem Laptop zum Beispiel mit dem SPI-Bus von irgendeinem kleinen Gerät reden, dann steckst du den Bus-Pirate per USB an deinen Rechner. Steckst den per USB an deinen Rechner. Und an die andere Seite, an diesen Pinheader da, steckst du dann die Kabel, die zu dem Gerät führen, mit dem du kommunizieren möchtest.
Das ist also extra dafür gemacht sozusagen, um dieses, ich muss mir jetzt nicht irgendwie Beinchen extra anlöten, sondern ich kann hier diese, das sieht aus wie so kleine Klemmen, kann ich sozusagen damit am Board an die passenden Punkte gehen.
Genau. Kann dann automatisch damit reden. Der Bus Pirate ist halt das Schöne daran, du kannst ihm halt sagen, verhalte dich mal wie ein SPI Interface oder verhalte dich mal wie ein I2C Interface. Du brauchst halt für diese ganzen Busse, die es so gibt, nicht für jedes ein eigenes Interface, sondern der kann die ganzen gängigen, der halt alle. Und es ist eine, ich finde es ganz nette Hardware, sie kostet auch relativ wenig Geld, kann man sehr viel Spaß mit haben.
Das faszinierend ist ja wirklich dieses Ding, womit man das am Board festmacht. Das ist so, das ist wie eine Spritze, wenn man es runter zieht, dann kommt so ein kleiner Haken raus, so eine kleine Zange, und damit kann man es anscheinend an diesen millimeterdünnen Beinchen auf einem Board irgendwie festmachen.
Wobei der Guz-Pilot eigentlich wiegt es schon sehr fast zu groß für das meiste.
Okay, wieso?
Weil wenn der den Nachbarn berührt, dann hast du halt einen Kurzschluss, deswegen muss man da schon sehr aufpassen.
Das sind ja nur diese Klemmerchen, die der Chinamann dabei gepackt hat, da kannst du ja auch dünnere Spitzen oder ein bisschen Fädeldraht dran machen.
So, haben wir jetzt die Werkzeuge durch eigentlich? Also hier steht noch was von Minicom, Pegelwandlern, U-Arts.
Der Pegelwandler ist im Bus-Pyrod auch mit eingebaut, ansonsten kennt man den zum Beispiel, so Datenkabel von Handys, moderne Geräte sprechen halt selten. Also die Serielle an deinem Rechner ist irgendwie sowas mit 8 Volt, und das haben die ganzen kleinen Boards nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, jetzt wird gefachsimpelt. Es gibt auf jeden Fall unterschiedliche Spannungen.
Jedenfalls ist der Logic Level, mit dem du mit den kleinen Geräten redest, selten der, den dein Computer hat. Und deswegen brauchst du halt einen Pegelwandler dazwischen, der dann auf den passenden Pegel wandelt.
Den FTDI-Chip von vorhin?
Zum Beispiel den FTDI-Chip, ja.
Wir sollten auf jeden Fall festhalten, dass die serielle Schnittstelle, von der wir die ganze Zeit geredet haben, an deinem Computer in aller Regel eine ganz andere ist, als die, die auf zum Beispiel Routern oder Kleinkomputern ist. Es ist keine ganz andere, es ist das selbe Protokoll, aber die serielle Schnittstelle namens RS232 an deinem Computer spricht von minus 20 bis plus 20 Volt. Und dein Router spricht dann halt, wie gesagt, von null bis fünf Volt. Und damit kannst du dir deinen Router ziemlich zerschießen.
Okay, das macht Sinn, da einen Pegelwandler dazwischen zu haben. Ich verstehe.
Damit es nicht raucht.
Das scheint mir überhaupt bei dieser ganzen Hardwarehacking-Geschichte ein wichtiges Kriterium zu sein, dass es nicht rauchen soll. Also ich will nicht sagen, ich habe jetzt gelernt, wie man Hardwarehacking macht. Aber ich habe eine grobe Idee, welche Begriffe ich nachschlagen muss. Hammer, ja, werde ich gleich ausprobieren nach der Sendung an unserem Sendequipment. Aber jetzt nochmal, wenn ich jetzt darauf Bock habe, wir haben am Anfang gesagt, wenn man anfangen will, Hardware zu hacken, dann kann man sich so einen Lötbausatz zum Beispiel kaufen und so was zusammenbauen. Jetzt habe ich aber diese ganzen Tools, die ihr gerade gesagt habt, das ist ja sozusagen an bestehender Hardware rumfrickeln. Wenn ich das jetzt machen will, wie fange ich da, wo am besten damit an? Zum Beispiel am liebsten wäre natürlich, wenn er sagte, benutze Geräte das und benutze Software-Suit das und das.
Dann sag mal, was du machen willst.
Du kannst es ja kombinieren. Du kannst dir zum Beispiel einen Pegelwandler löten. Dann hast du dir ein Werkzeug gebaut und gelötet. Das ist auch nicht schwierig. Da gibt es fertige Bausätze.
Aber dann hab ich ja schon wieder was gebaut. Ich will ja was sagen. Das finde ich ja dieses Spannende. Da kann ich auch den Reiz nachvollziehen. Ich möchte das Gerät und ich möchte mit dem Gerät etwas machen oder darüber etwas wissen, was eigentlich nicht vorgesehen ist. Mirko hat sehr viel über Route erzählt. Ist das sozusagen the way to go? Nimm doch mal deinen Router auseinander und bau eine Steckdose. Dieses Projekt, was du da gemacht hast, dieses irgendwie Funksteckdose im Baumarkt kaufen, dann Router so bauen, dass er den steuern kann. Meinst du, man könnte damit anfangen oder ist das schon eine Spur zu haben?
Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen ein hoher Einstieg. Aber vielleicht kaufst du halt so ein Arduino-Bastelboard und da braucht man fast eigentlich gar keine Tools, weil das wäre bestimmt eine Menge beschrieben, da man aber grundsätzlich immer Fehler macht. Brauchst du halt einen Voltmeter, einen Lüttkolben und vielleicht, wenn du mit deinem Arduino richtig professionell backen willst, einen Auslöskop.
Was ist denn die Uhr?
Ja, ich... Ja, wie soll man sagen? Ich wollte mir mal eine eigene Uhr bauen. Und zwar, ich hatte so eine Uhr in so einem uralten Radiowecker und der hatte so eine Siebensegment-Anzeige. So richtig 30, 40 Jahre alt. Keine Ahnung. Sah aber immer gut aus, weil sieben Segment, war aber schön groß. Alle moderneren Dinger, die da so kamen, waren immer so LCD und die mussten beleuchtet sein. Und das LCD-Finish sieht auch einfach nicht gut aus. Ich wollte große Siebensegment-Anzeigen haben. Und dann dachte ich, ich baue mir so eine Uhr selber, wenn es so etwas nicht mehr gibt. Und habe mir das halt gebaut. Und zwar dann halt noch mit diesem Funkempfang DCF77, dass sie ihre Uhrzeit selber über... Genau. Und ich wollte das haben, einfach nur als Uhr. Kein Wecker, kein gar nichts. Sondern einfach nur sich selber einstellen und die Uhr anzeigen. Und ich hatte null Ahnung von nichts damals, also nicht viel. Und musste halt alles Mögliche rausfinden, was ich für Bausteine nehme. Und selbst was ich für Widerstände nehme, damit die LEDs nicht kaputt gehen, weil die sollen ja nicht 5 Volt kriegen, sondern kriegen ein bisschen weniger und so weiter und so fort. Und dann muss man sich halt da so einfummeln. Und dann ist es am besten noch gut, wenn man einen hat, den man fragen kann oder mehrere, damit man nicht einen allzu viel nervt. Und dann schlägt man halt sich so durch. Und ich habe mehrere Prototypen gebaut. Und auch mit einem Kumpel am Anfang zusammen, der das eigentlich eine Menge gemacht hat. Und dann habe ich halt immer mehr selber gemacht. Und dann kennt man immer mehr und kann immer größere Projekte wagen und so. Und so habe ich halt irgendwie angefangen. Und da brauchst du auch Lötkolben. Multimeter ist irgendwie das Wichtigste eigentlich.
Okay, jetzt habe ich noch eine Frage. Ihr seid ja gerne und schnell dabei, wenn jemand im Club kommt, wie seid ihr die Reparierer? Wenn jetzt jemand in dem Status ist, der sagt, ich würde das gerne mal ausprobieren. Aber du sagst ja auch die ganze Zeit, es ist immer gut, wenn man jemanden hat, der das kennt, kann man mit sowas irgendwie.
Na manchmal weiß man einfach gar nicht, was es für Möglichkeiten gibt, gerade als Anfänger. Und dann braucht man mal hier so einen erfahrenen Menschen, der sagt, hier, du baust das und das, guck doch mal, da gibt es folgenden Stein, der macht das für dich oder folgendes Tool oder folgende Software, die hilft dir dabei und dann kommst du gleich viel weiter.
Noch viel einfacher, das Gerät geht nicht mehr an. Dann kann man es auch erstmal aufschrauben und gucken, ob jetzt hinter dem Schalter z.B. genau Spannung ankommt oder so.
Die Frage, die ich stellen wollte, ist, kann so jemand, der jetzt die Sendung gehört, aber ich hab halt niemanden im sozialen Umfeld, kann er dann hierher kommen und nochmal gucken?
Das ist immer schwierig, weil da kommt immer eine Menge Leute, die man nicht weiß, wie ernst sie das meinen. Also wenn einer mit seinem großen Sack an Elektrobasselkram kommt und sagt, ich blicke da nicht durch und ich will, aber das ist ein bisschen ähnlich, wie die Leute, die reinkommen und sagen, sag mal, ihr seid doch hier so im Hacken und könnt ihr mal schnell das Hacken beibringen und dann senken wir schon alle den Kopf.
Ich meinte natürlich genau das nicht.
Ich glaube, wenn er sagen kann, ich habe mich die letzten drei Tage damit beschäftigt, habe versucht, es selber zu machen, bin so und so weit gekommen, aber jetzt hänge ich hier fest. So eine spezielle, genaue Frage stellen, dann auf jeden Fall immer, aber nicht hier einfach hinschmeißen und die macht auch mal für mich.
Wir haben jetzt auch seit mehreren Monaten jede Woche fast einen Gast, der sich eine alte Drum Machine als Bausatz zusammenbaut. Und der hat das halt auch, ja, 90% davon schafft er alleine, aber ab und zu fragt dann mal irgendjemand hier, wie löse ich denn das am besten? Und ich glaube, sowas geht eigentlich ziemlich gut. Hier wird dir niemand Händchen halten, aber wenn du eine Frage vernünftig formuliert bekommst, kriegst du für gewöhnlich auch eine vernünftige Antwort.
Und unser Chaos Communication Congress ist ja auch schon wieder sehr nah und da wird es auch wieder ganz viele Hardware-Bastler geben.
Und eventuell, ich glaube jetzt hier auf dem VOCFB, auf dem Vintage Computing Festival Berlin, da war ja auch so eine Reparaturecke, da saßen zwei, drei Leute, die sich sehr gut auskannten. Und dann konnten die Leute mit ihrer Vintage Hardware dahin kommen und sagen, hier guck mal, mein uraltes Kettenlaufwerk von 54 tut irgendwie nicht mehr und kannst du mal ein bisschen gucken und so. Und ich glaube, da wurden einige Sachen repariert, weil alte Sachen gehen ja doch auch immer irgendwie kaputt. Und wenn ich mich nicht recht täusche, dann ist da auch der Plan, das auf dem Chaos-Kongress jetzt zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr auch zu wiederholen.
Dazu kommen wir gleich zum Vintage Computing Festival. Noch sagen, hört die letzte Chaos-Radiosendung. Da ging es natürlich darum. Und wir spielen jetzt noch eine kleine Musik. Und dann haben wir noch eine halbe Stunde für Hardwarehacking. Die Musik kommt von Mr. Beep, Slowing Down the Chaos, ZX48. Das ist eigentlich ein schöner Titel für diese Sendung, Slowing Down the Chaos beim Chaosradio. So, Slowing Down the Chaos von Mr. B hier im Chaos Radio 206, wo wir jetzt schon eineinhalb Stunden über Hardwarehacking geredet haben. Und, also, wie soll ich sagen, man kann es wahrscheinlich nicht eins zu eins sofort nachmachen, aber es ist schon ein guter Einstieg, wenn man mal grob wissen will, worum es geht. Und wir haben noch ein schönes Beispiel, zu Hause der Berliner Chaos Computer Club hat hier noch ein schönes Beispiel. Und zwar hängt hier im Club so eine riesiges, ja so eine Infotafel, die aus vielen kleinen LEDs besteht, die aber irgendwie dann auch angesteuert werden. Also das ist anscheinend auch gehackt worden. Was ist da los?
Na, die hat der Annemar Margun vor vielen Jahren mal bei eBay gekauft, die Anzeige.
Sag mal erst mal, was das ist eigentlich, damit man sich...
Na, wir, manche sagen, es ist ein Flughafendisplay, aber ich glaube, unseres hier waren die auf einem Flughafen, das war ja so ein Vorführgerät, da stand da was von Vorführung in Saal 1 und so. Es war schon in die LEDs so eingebrannt. Also die sind schwächer an der Stelle, ist ein bisschen ausgelutscht. Aber es ist eine große Anzeige. Die kann auch in einem Flughafen gehangen haben, aber es wäre wahrscheinlich ein kleinerer Flughafen.
Könnt ihr euch auch angucken, der ist streaming.media.ccc.de. Was musste da gehackt werden? Ich denke, das schließt man wie ein Bildschirm an den Rechner an, und dann ist gut.
Na, da war halt, ist halt so ein kleiner Mikrocontroller drin gewesen. Und das hat ja erst mal so funktioniert, wie wir das bekommen haben. Aber es war halt zu langsam. Es konnte nur ASCII-Zeichen anzeigen und kein Video. Und es ist auch zu langsam einfach. Und es stand hier ein gefühltes Jahr in der Ecke und keiner hat sich mit beschäftigt. Alle Leute, die Ahnung hatten, haben sich nicht damit beschäftigt. Und irgendwie hatte ich Langeweile. Und ich glaube, es war auch zu der Zeit, wo ich mir endlich dann doch mal nach Jahrzehnten ein eigenes Multimeter gekauft habe. Und dachte ich jetzt, ich brauche irgendwas zum Hacken. Und wollte mal loslegen und habe mir halt ein so ein Modul da ausgebaut. Habe es mit nach Hause genommen und habe mich da stundenlang hingesetzt und habe halt die Leitung durchgepiept, von welchem Anschluss das zu welchem Beinchen geht. Und habe mir sozusagen den Schallplan so langsam nachgezeichnet. Habe mir besorgt, da sind so Maxim-Chips drin, so für LED-Ansteuerung. Habe geguckt, was das für einer ist und wie die funktionieren und worum welche Beinchen wir ankommen, welche Leitungen. Und habe halt langsam rausgefunden, wie es funktioniert. Und habe dann, glaube ich, auch in der Zeit so einen kleinen Arduino gehabt.
Was ist das eigentlich?
Das ist auch so ein kleiner Mikrocontroller, der ist gerade ganz angesagt. Damit kann man auch, gibt es schon so ein Fertig-IDEe, was man sich für seinen Rechner runterladen kann. Oder man kann ja auch selber mit seiner Softwareflasche, da kann man halt, da sind auch so diese sogenannten GPIOs drauf, also so Ein- und Ausgabeleitungen.
Das ist Kanze blinken lassen.
Kanze blinken lassen.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was auch so ein pädagogisches, also ist direkt dafür gemacht, dass man damit auch lernen kann.
Das hat eine Designhochschule ursprünglich losgetreten.
In Italien.
Genau, weil die das Problem hatten, dass diese Design-Studenten ja keine Technik-Studenten waren. Aber heute muss ja alles blinken. Und da haben sie halt versucht, etwas zu entwickeln, womit man möglichst leicht, ohne viel Programmierkenntnisse in einer sehr einfachen Sprache, Lämmchen blinken, kleine Mooteurchen bewegen kann. Also die haben den Chip nicht erfunden, aber die Entwicklungsumgebung dafür und das ganze Board halt.
Genau, das gibt es bis heute noch. Das ist auch so eine Art Standard. Das ist so ein bisschen nicht Raspberry Pi, aber deren Erfolg war dadurch, dass sie halt ganz viele davon gekauft haben. Und deswegen gibt es ganz viele Internetseiten, die sich damit beschäftigen und Aufsätze, sogenannte Shields anbieten. Und dann kann man da ganz viel mitmachen. Und jedenfalls so einen hatte ich, hab den dann halt an dieses Modul, was ich hatte, angeschlossen und hab halt so lange gebastelt und programmiert und gemessen und getan, bis ich halt selber geschafft hab, Daten in diese eine Leiste, die ich da mitgenommen hab, irgendwie reinzuschieben. Und als ich das dann hatte, dachte ich, okay, dann jetzt immer mehrere Leisten und dann mal alle Leisten. Und so habe ich mich langsam halt nach vorne gearbeitet. Und über die Jahre wurde es dann mal besser, besser, schneller, schneller. Und bis es halt heute so ist, wie es ist.
Jetzt kann man ja wirklich sagen, wie auf dem Flughafen schon diese Anzeigen, wo halt Abflug und Anflug angegeben werden. Aber man kann jetzt Videos draufgucken und das ging uns an.
Ja, das ging uns gar nicht. Da konnte man zugucken, wie die Zeichen so langsam ins Display geschoben wurden.
Also wirklich so wie früher so die Flap-Dinger, wo es halt wirklich alle paar Sekunden hat es mal irgendwie die Dings umgeschaltet. Und inzwischen ist es 50 Hertz Video.
Also wenn ihr Hardwarehacking anfangen könntet das eines sein, was dann später, wenn ihr richtig fit seid, an den Start kommen kann. So, jetzt haben wir noch so ein paar Sachen für Leute, die anfangen. Ich hab schon geklärt, wenn man eine konkrete Frage hat und schon auf dem halben Weg ist, da kann man noch gerne herkommen und mal gucken, ob jemand helfen kann. Aber jetzt zum Anfang. Habt ihr so ein paar Quellen gesammelt, wo ihr sagt, okay damit könnte man vielleicht an den Start gehen und mal so gucken, wie man ganz von vorne anfängt. Also so ein Arduino hab ich jetzt schon gehört, das kann man da schon auch machen oder so Bausätze zum Selberlöten kaufen. Was gibt es denn noch?
Also für die Inspiration gibt es da so eine Webseite, die Hardwarehacks sammelt, das ist hackaday.com und die listet immer mal wieder interessante Hardwarehacks auf, wo man als normalsterblicher Mensch eigentlich gar nicht drauf kommt, was man so mit welchen Geräten noch so anstellen kann. Und das ist da durchzuscrollen und sich das anzugucken, was da Leute gemacht haben.
Aber ist das eher so, guck mal hier, dass ihr geil ist oder auch so mit Anleitung?
Das ist dann immer so eine kurze Zusammenfassung und verweist dann meistens auf so Blogposts, wo die Leute, die das gemacht haben, beschreiben, wie sie darauf gekommen sind, was sie genau gemacht haben. Source Kurzverfügung stellen, Tools, die sie verwendet haben. Das ist schon meistens sehr elaboriert alles.
Also zum Beispiel der Roomba, dieser automatische Staubsauger, der halt irgendwie immer nur rechts rumfährt und die hätten halt gerne, dass er links rumfährt. Und dann gibt es zum Beispiel irgendwie hier, du musst das und das machen und dann fährt er auch links rum.
Ja, es gibt ein tolles Buch. Hacking the Xbox heißt das von Bani Hung. Das ist jemand, der sich sehr viel mit Hardware beschäftigt. Und in diesem Buch hat er niedergelegt, wie er sich damals die erste Spielekonsole, diese Xbox, geschnappt hat und halt versucht hat, die zu hacken. Und als er damit angefangen hat, war er halt auch noch relativ unversiert und hat sich seine ganzen Tools nach und nach erarbeitet und selber entwickelt und erzählt halt, wie das alles so passiert ist. Es ist sehr schön zu lesen und gibt einem auf jeden Fall einen tollen Einblick in was man so machen kann und wie man so dahinter kommt, wie man selber dahinter kommt, wie was funktioniert.
Also auch so die Basics leider halt inzwischen auch schon wieder ein bisschen älter. Aber so wirklich die Grundlagen finden wir relativ.
Aber so eine Xbox zum Hacken ist ja dafür auch nicht mehr so teuer.
Genau, das Buch kann man auch kostenlos online beziehungsweise als E-Book lesen oder sicher halt kaufen. Gibt es auch hackingsxbox.com?
Ich erinnere mich noch, dass wir damals bei der PlayStation 1 tatsächlich von Hand einen Chip raufgelötet haben, um Homebrew Software laufen zu lassen.
Hast du das gemacht?
Ich glaube, ich habe es mal versucht. Es hat nicht geklappt und wir hatten an einem Freundeskreis sozusagen den Spezialexperten dafür. Wie ist denn das heute eigentlich? Spielt das bei Konsolen überhaupt noch eine Rolle? Weil ich habe das letzte Mal, als ich von einem Konsolenhack gehört habe, da war es auf einem Kongress für die Playstation 3 und da ging es irgendwie um Super-Kryptographie und weiß-der-geil-er-was.
Also wie ich vorhin auch schon meinte, die Hardwarehacking ist eigentlich die Vorstufe für Software. Heutzutage ist überall Software drin. Also in der Regel sind tatsächlich so Spielkonsolenhacks inzwischen größtenteils Software-Sachen.
Also die Xbox One zum Beispiel war, ich glaube, die erste Spielekonsole, die eigentlich ein ganz normaler Computer war. Da war ein x86er Prozessor drin, da lief ein Betriebssystem und entsprechend konnte man auf Software-Ebene da angreifen.
So, gibt es noch mehr Anlaufstellen für Neulinge?
Also die Betreiber der Hackaday-Seite veranstalten ein Event in München am 13. November und haben dazu die R-Verkreis, also die CCC-Ableger in ganz Deutschland eingeladen. Und da werden mit Sicherheit sehr interessante Projekte präsentiert.
Also Hackaday ist jetzt was Einmaliges oder ist das eine Veranstaltung, die häufiger stattfindet?
Also die kommen aus Amerika, dort gibt es das schon öfter. In Deutschland ist das glaube ich das erste Mal.
Ja, dann was vielleicht noch zu nennen wäre, wenn man sich erstmal so ganz grundlegend mit wie die ganzen Rechner und so funktionieren. Die Fiona, die neulich auch mal beim Chaos Radio dabei war, nee war sie nicht, sie war krank. Sie wollte dabei sein. Genau, die hat einen Podcast dazu, Noobcore heißt der, wo sie sehr einfach den Leuten erklärt, wie Computer funktionieren. Das ist sicherlich auch ein schöner Einstieg. Dann gibt es eine, naja, es ist eine Firma, Adafruit heißen sie, die machen sehr viele kleine Bausätze. Du fragst das ja früher nach Bausätzen und sie haben auch unter learn.adafruit.com sehr schön geschrieben How-To's, wie man sehr einfach Dinge machen kann und sehr schön erklärt, wie das alles funktioniert.
Okay, so das sind die Dinge, mit denen ihr euch beschäftigen könnt, wenn ihr das mal anfangen wollt. Bevor wir dann zu den Hausmeister-Reihen am Ende noch kommen, da gibt es noch so ein paar Termine zu kündigen. Was ist denn jetzt sozusagen, also zwei Fragen an jeden von euch noch mal. Das eine ist, was ist euer nächstes Projekt? Und das andere ist, was würdet ihr gerne mal sehen? Wo denkt ihr, da müsste eigentlich mal jemand?
Das nächste Hardware-Projekt? Weiß ich gerade gar nicht. André, erst mal zuerst, ich muss überlegen.
Ich muss auch überlegen.
Ist das sozusagen Hardwarehacking? Nichts, was man längerfristig plant? Dann fällt einem das Gerät auf den Fuß und denkt, jetzt könnte ich aber auch mal.
Eigentlich ist es genauso. Irgendwie macht das Gerät nicht genau das, was man möchte, oder zu wenig. Oder die Schmerzschwelle ist überschritten, wo man denkt, verdammt, jetzt kann ich das nicht mehr aussitzen. Sondern muss da mal Hand anlegen und versucht, die Situation zu verbessern.
Hardwarehacking im klassischen Sinne auch. Mein nächstes Projekt wird sich mit Fußfesseln beschäftigen. Also die Dinge, die die Gefangenen an den Fuß kriegen.
Hast du der Scheiß gemacht, Starbuck?
Ich hab tatsächlich keinen. Aber ich zück mir gerne mal die Sicherheit von ihm an. Wie hardwaremäßig sichergestellt wird, dass das nicht abgenommen werden kann. Was da so viel Hardware drin ist. Zum Beispiel ein GPS-Modul, ein GSM-Modul. Wie die miteinander kommunizieren und wann sie was tun.
Hast du schon eine Erschätzung, wie hoch der Verbrauch sein wird?
Das Problem ist, man kann sie tatsächlich nicht kaufen in Deutschland und auch in Amerika nicht. Sie werden halt verliehen an den Staat oder an die Gefängnisse. Alibaba hat sie im 5000er Stückzahl als kleinstes, glaube ich. Das heißt, wenn ich welche hab, dann hab ich genug. Okay, also die Beschaffung ist tatsächlich derzeit das Problem.
Crowdfunding für 5000 Fußwässer kaufen.
Ich versuche irgendwie halt mal so leihweise, beziehungsweise, ich geh mir immer so...
Könnten sie mir mal ein Muster schicken.
Genau, ein Muster.
Alle kleinen Kriminellen, die so ein Ding haben und sowieso auf der Flucht sind, die den abgemacht haben können, bitte mal hierher schicken.
Das wäre tatsächlich...
Oder einfach nachts um drei bei Starbuck klopfen, wenn sie noch am Fuß ist.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ob ich das jetzt noch mal irgendwie kommentieren sollte.
Ja, es liegt momentan unten im Keller. Dieses Amazon Fire TV, so das Apple TV für die Nicht-Ei-Besitzer. Das ist in der europäischen Version leider momentan noch nicht rudbar oder hackbar. Und da sitzen wir gerade dran und schauen mal, was man da noch so machen kann.
Inwiefern was man da noch so machen kann?
Na ja, also genau das, was wir vorhin so angesprochen haben. Die Schnittstellen auf den Boards sind mittlerweile alle bekannt. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie man über eine der Schnittstellen dem Gerät andere Software zum Buten gibt, als es von Werk aus hatte, damit es das tut, was man will.
Und das macht man als hätt ich dann sagen, indem man sich irgendwie so Datenströme anguckt und sagt, da schick ich vielleicht noch mal ein umgekipptes Bit rein und dann ist das alles anders?
Hoffentlich muss es nicht so weit gehen. Der momentane Plan ist ein bisschen einfacher. Also diese auf der Platine von dem Board ist wiederum ein Flash-Speicher. In diesem Fall etwas, was so ähnlich funktioniert wie eine SD-Karte. Und die Hoffnung ist, mit diesem Flash-Speicher reden zu können, ohne ihn vorher von dem Board runterkratzen zu müssen, weil der leider außen keine Beinchen hat, wo man sich einfach dranhängen kann. Und wenn das klappt, dann kann man mit ihm halt reden, so ähnlich als wäre es eine SD-Karte. Und dann kann man einfach die Software reintun, die man da drin haben möchte. Zumindest so der Plan.
Ben, ist das so noch was?
Aber es kommt auf jeden Fall immer irgendwie was. Software machen wir ja auch noch. Da ist ja kein wirkliches Hardwarehacking. Da wird dann Strom angeschlossen und fertig.
Mirko, noch ganz kurz, du bist ja bei den Freifunkern auch. Du hast jetzt schon ganz viel von Rudern auch erzählt. Ist das auch irgendwie mit Antennenbau und sowas, ist das auch Hardwarehacking? Oder ist das eigentlich...
Oh ja, in der Tat. Aber...
Das fragst du mich jetzt fünf Minuten vorhin in der Sendung.
In der C-Base immer passiert in Berlin und Antennenbau ist so ein Voodoo-Thema. Weil man sieht einfach nicht, was da durch die Luft, was da über den Eta geht. Und man erinnert sich glaube ich noch, jeder hat es mal gemacht, irgendwie so eine Antenne in der Hand gehabt und versucht die so zu richten, dass irgendwie der Fernseh-Ampfang besser wurde. Und man kann halt nicht das Ganze als normaler Nutzer auf theoretischem Niveau nachzuvollziehen. Das ist einfach schlicht wett unmöglich. Also es gibt ja nicht einfach Tools, die man sich für wenig Geld kaufen kann, wo man dann sieht, in welche Richtung genau diese Wellen gehen und wo man die Antenne aufzustellen hat, wo man sie zu verbessern hat. Das ist alles irgendwie ein großes Trial and Error. Und das wurde exzessiv in der Seaways praktiziert und zum Optimum gebracht, sodass da Antennen gebaut wurden, womit man WLAN-Richtfunkstrecken von einem Bezirk in den nächsten gebaut hat. Das waren auch meine Volksgeschichten.
Aber das ist jetzt so, dass ihr da am Ende seid. Also da ist quasi jetzt das fertig und ihr habt für, wenn ihr irgendwo Antennen aufs Dach setzt, habt ihr dann halt auch schon fertige Baupläne zumindest. Tja, falls ihr noch was zu forschen habt, könnt ihr es gerne in die Kommentare zur Sendung schreiben. Wir sind ja glaube ich im Hardwarehacking auch durch. Ist der denn hier im Saal? Schreit jetzt gleich noch einer? Nein, ich möchte auch noch was sagen. Schreit der Saal?
Die schlafen alle schon.
Ich brauche das nächste Mal für so ein Tumbleweed-Geräusch für meine Soundkarte. So, es gibt aber noch ein paar Termine, die ihr ansagen wolltet. Also ich vermute zumindest mal, dass es am Ende des Jahres einen Kongress gibt.
Es gibt zum Ende des Jahres einen Kongress. Und zwar den 31. vom 26. Dezember bis zum 30. Dezember.
Vom 26.
Nicht 27.
Wir sind eher am 26.
Wenn Leute noch viel mithelfen wollen, dann kommen die schon einen Tag früher.
Also es geht am 27. Dezember geht der Kongress los. Und sozusagen alle, die früher da sind, die armen Schweine, die arbeiten müssen.
Und es wird eine Hardware- und Making-Track-Game, wo genau solche Hardware-Hacks präsentiert werden, auch auf dem Kongress. Und es wird eine Reihe von Workshops geben, wo man dann auch hands-on nachmachen, mitmachen kann, gezeigt bekommt, was alles so möglich ist und so weiter.
Okay, gibt es schon Tickets?
Nein, aber bald.
Gibt es genug Tickets?
Es gibt dieses Jahr genug Tickets.
Doch, doch, doch. Okay, sehr schön. Gibt es noch andere Dinge, die anzusagen sind? Ich lese hier noch etwas von einem Heidelberg.
Also es gibt, wie auch glaube ich fast alle letzten Jahre, die RGB 2R. Ich weiß nicht genau, was ist ausgesprochen. Doch, Root Gag Back to the Root. Also es ist ein Retro Gaming Event. Also sozusagen wie die Vintage Computing, halt bloß mit Spielen. Das heißt, da hast du einen alten C64 oder deinen Super NES oder noch viel ältere Hardware, so Pong und sowas. Und sie treffen sich in Heidelberg vom 31.10. bis 2.11. Und einfach mal nach RGB2R googeln und dann findet man die nötigen Informationen.
Und dann kommt FIF nach Berlin?
Das ist bald, das ist dieses Wochenende. Das ist jetzt sozusagen.
Also wenn die Sendung vorbei ist, dann geht's los. In der Tat, geht aber bis 2.11. Was ist FIF? Was machen die hier in Berlin? Was ist da los?
Das ist das Forum für InformatikerInnen für Frieden und gesellschaftliche Verantwortung. Die machen eine Konferenz mit dem Titel Der Fall des Geheimen. Ein Blick unter den eigenen Teppich. Geht halt um das ganze Thema Whistle Blowing und verantwortungsvolle Umgang mit Wissen, glaube ich.
In inklusive mehrerer CCC Größen als Vortragender. Mit Organisatoren, glaube ich auch zumindest Unterstützer. F-I-F-F dort irgendwas auch einfach mal googeln.
Eintritt ist frei, Um-Anmeldung wird gebeten und das Ganze wird auch gestreamt werden. Also wer es nicht hinschafft, kann es auch von zu Hause angucken. Das ist in Berlin.
Du weißt nicht von wo der Stream kommt.
Schaut in das Internet, wir hören aus dem OF TU.
In der TU, ja, das ist ja noch präziser.
So, dann vielen Dank fürs Mitmachen an Dennis, Starbark, Peter, Mirko, Danimo, Wetter, die Shownotes, die auf dem Sofa sitzen und alle anderen, die mitgemacht haben. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Ihr könnt diese Folge, wenn ihr sie gehört habt, gerne kommentieren, denn Applaus und Kommentare sind der Lohn des Künstlers. Chaosradio.ccc.de, da findet ihr alles. Falls ihr schon vergessen habt, wo ihr diesen Podcast runtergeladen habt, nachdem ihr ihn gehört habt. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich hab euch nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Tschüss.